[Music]
two hello everybody it is Monday another
week
shows
1:30 p.m. October 23rd Halloween is this
weekend or next
week it's exciting guys we can I can
taste the uh buttercups already or
whatever they're
called I am so excited buttercups what
their oh peanut butter is that what
you're saying butter you can see my eyes
are absolutely look at my face all
weekend long everyone's like dude what
is wrong what is happening and I just I
had do explain it like 10
times I hate that red I'll tell you
guys I was on steroid cream and some
other one every day for a month color
cream different flavors of ointment
they're all different
flavors people are saying you look extra
lupy today thank you guys for
acknowledging that that's you know it's
nice to finally get thanks you guys some
recognition Zach welcome back by the way
thank you very much good to be back good
to be back appreciate
itary always a pleasure you know I miss
Zach so much when he's gone it's just
not the same miss you what were you
doing you were at a I was a groomsman in
a wedding how was that it was fun it was
a good time it was a lot of fun first
time doing that uh Second second time
were you under the hoopa and the sun uh
goam wedding so uh I was go I was an
outcast yeah were you in the sun though
yes I don't know what it is with
weddings whenever you're especially when
you're part of
the bridal Group whatever you just your
job is to stand in the Sun during the
hottest day of the year and die that's
like every wedding am I wrong what's
going on it was right at uh like Sundown
so it was like Primo right in the every
time and like I get red face so easy so
wasn't doing any favors you might want
to see a rheumatologist about that yeah
you and me both man I'd be your Loop
yeah anyway welcome back thank you good
to be back yeah so uh I stopped using
the steroid cream and the the other one
and then it over the next 3 days came
back like
worse worse than
ever and it's just been getting worse so
I went to the dermatologist this morning
for an
emergency
meeting and now they gave me a new one
called and you got you all you armchair
doctors can tell
me esolve ointment
no that's what they gave you I 2% no
it's called um oh that's the wrong thing
dude AR throy 2% what does chat think
about Ary aromy 2% do we like it stop
laughing not I think a good what do you
even AR what is it I'll spell it it's e
r y t h r o m y c i n oh arith yeah
arroy you know about that oh right boy
oh yeah I just I've heard it prescribed
many times for a few things that's all I
know what does that mean that's wait
what does that mean that's so cryptic
what did you get no no I just mean like
the way you were saying I didn't
recognize what it was at first oh you've
heard of this drug before so I'm I'm
apply I wanted to apply it for you guys
live it's it's like a Vaseline so my
face is going to be all shiny and this
is why you know no there's no podcast I
am a surgeon there's no podcast like
this one because nobody brings their
medical issues to the screen like I
do very divided on uh the chemical by
the way really yeah 6040 oh you did a
poll yeah
I'm gonna have to send that to my doctor
excuse me doctor only uh 60% agreed with
your diagnosis no I think it's a good
vibe H God it's the worst part is the
corner of my eyes
here oh dude all right let me get
the other eye so um Ethan
okay by the way as I thank you everybody
we don't have sponsors today so thank
you especially to our
members
you guys make the world go round for
this show you guys do so much to help
support us and I'm very very very
appreciative so thank you to all of our
this show is supported
by people like you
ah God actually I was thinking it didn't
really hurt but now it does when I touch
it like that yeah maybe maybe that's
maybe don't touch well I have to yeah
yeah but like after I don't yeah I don't
I don't usually
like with it
you know what I mean
mhhm it looks like it like stings yeah
it does now when I'm touching but like
what is this I've been dealing with this
for so long I feel like I don't
know it's lupus for sure it's got to be
I'm sold I was doubting for a long time
but uh it's probably not what else could
it be I think it's lopus you do should
we do a poll I think it is let's do a
poll let's do a lupus poll I'll send a
poll to my rheumatologist we'll see does
Ethan have Lupus yeah come on you guys
this come on this is the real here we go
we've been waiting for well we ped
30,000 doctors and I really believe here
we go here we go that's what I expected
look at the PO oh my God it's
overwhelming it's overwhelming what did
they say 71% say you have Lupus that's
what I thought yeah yeah yeah yeah dude
if you if you did a survey of 10 doctors
and seven of seven of them gave the same
diagnosis you got that for sure so
I hate to be the bear of bad
news what's up with those three those
three doctors that aren't on the lupus
train well I'm just talking about like
as a right yeah all right so I think I
got my medicine all applied here and as
I understand by the end of the show it
should all be gone all the
bo you look
it's a good one right you look
crazy I'm sure I'm sure whenever I look
crazy is when I do something that goes
viral yeah oh no uh so I'm pretty sure
that people are going to see this you
look like um you look like that Tim
hieker character um Casey yeah he's got
all like bruised up on his face yeah and
Vaseline shiny beautiful you look like
Anakin when he just fell to the dark
side about to go slay some younglings
right now that's how and that's a good
segue that's how people are talking
about me they think I'm Anakin about to
go slice up some
younglings all right I want there's
something I have to
say about I'm G to say drama just some
there's been conversations thank you Dan
that does is surprisingly
accurate is he drooling not think so
yeah okay or it might just be the veline
pooling I am not ring but it's like in
uh Raiders of the Lost arc when that one
guy melts to death you know from looking
at the arc okay yeah mhm that's me did
he have Lupus he might have dude it may
not have been the arc it may have been
undiagnosed lupus just
lupus so hold on one sec so I'm going to
touch on this fast and I'm going try to
be calm okay I'm I'm I'm going to keep
it together I'm going to do
this you can turn off chat too cuz I
don't want I don't I don't thank you I
don't want I don't need need people
arguing in the comments
okay do it here's what I'm going to say
I'm try to express myself
calmly so when talking about this
conflict between Israel and uh
Gaza Palestinians because I mean they're
they're they bombed the West Bank too so
it's kind of everywhere now but
when talking about this I've noticed a
strange phenomenon and and I want to
explain to you what I see so that you
can hopefully
emphasize with what I'm trying to convey
when I talk about things that happened
uh in this
conflict so when the massacre happened
on October
7th and terrorists and came into you
know Israel and slaughtered 1300
people
horrible there was a lot of people
though that were cheering on Hamas
explicitly a lot were doing it
explicitly just saying like hey this is
what a revolution looks
like and there was a lot of people who
said as the bodies were you know still
being counted Israel hadn't done
anything in response
uh it was the same day I mean you know
they were still cleaning
up the massacre and people were saying
uh as the news broke people don't want
to hear about timing but I'm just
telling you my perspective as the news
broke before expressing condolences or
out or like horror it was free
Palestine now I'm free Palestine you can
say pre pre free Palestine but the
timing to me made me uncomfortable it
seemed like they were cheering on
Hamas so when I try to convey that
there's so many people that go oh come
on saying free Palestine as people are
as terrorists are in kabut killing
people that's not cheering on Hamas
that's just you know
us we just really rooting for Palestine
the time doesn't matter I say okay fine
I'm not going to argue that anymore but
when the bombs start dropping right when
Israel does retaliate a few days later
or I don't know if might even the the
next day I I don't remember the
timeline then all of a sudden it's
insensitive to talk about it because it
doesn't matter because uh Israel's
bombing Gaza
okay so as the bombing
continues the next thing I start hearing
is you know
the Hamas terrorists who went there they
were just there to take hostages they
they didn't kill they weren't there to
kill as many people as possible they
were to they didn't rape anyone they
didn't kill kids they didn't behead
anyone and this became the new
thing where they're trying to you know
almost like hey dude Hamas isn't that
bad you know like we're exaggerating
what they did there there's you know
what I mean and so when I want to say
when I see people saying that and I want
to respond to it I say yeah actually
Hamas did kill babies they did rape
women they did decapitate people they
did burn families alive okay you know
what now's not the
time it's not the time you're being
insensitive to what's happening in Gaza
now's not the time I say okay now's not
the
time bombs are falling it's not the
time then when a when this Hospital gets
blown up
and there's a whole day of hysterical
coverage of
it people saying upwards to 900 people
died
horrific um the result of which was mass
riots around the
world and escalation of tensions with
neighboring
countries
so at the time it's like listen let's
let's wait and see you know let's wait
and see and let the news come out cuz
this is all reported by the uh
Palestinian uh or the gazen health
Ministry but by the
way Gaza Health Min Ministry is run by
Hamas terrorist
organization that killed 1300
people so they said dude how dare you
question it
how dare you you know Israel bombed it
you scumbag how dare
you doesn't it doesn't even matter if
they did that's the new thing it doesn't
matter because Israel's bombed lots of
other hospitals Israel's bombed 15 or
damaged 15 hospitals in the last 10
years so it doesn't matter that this one
of the biggest hospitals in Gaza was the
story was blown up and killed 900 people
let's wait for information some
reasonable people said scumbag they say
Zionist okay fine now's not the time
now's not the
time the next day when you find out the
hospital was
undamaged the explosion was from a stray
rocket okay that was shot by terrorists
in Gaza the specifically the jihadist uh
the pal inan jihadist group something
like that not Hamas interestingly but I
guess another terrorist
organization so when it comes out and
please let's not debate
it
it's it's almost certain at this point
that it was a it was a rocket from Gaza
that that what caused this so what
actually happened is a rocket was Miss
fired or
malfunctioned fell in the parking lot
and it killed 300 people approximately
we don't really know the truth is there
was a lot of people who were uh taking
Refuge around the hospital because they
thought it was a safe place as well they
should be you know what I mean they
should assume
that but and and unfortunately this
rocket
malfunctioned it was a massive rocket
headed to you know the heart of is Isel
it was full of fuel and so when the
rudder malfunction and this rocket full
of fuel dropped down into the parking
lot it exploded into a a ball of
Napal scorching the parking lot and
killing a ton of people tragically
horrible
horrible and so now when it's like
actually the Israelis didn't blow up the
hospital and kill 900 people actually it
was the terrorists there who were
shooting a rocket from over a
hospital that malfunctioned and they
killed 300 of their own
people it doesn't matter I can't you
can't talk about this cuz now is not the
time it's not the time to talk about
this how dare
you how dare you for even saying it
Israel has bombed other hospitals so
like you know what I mean who cares if
it was true or not who
cares first of all it does matter and
this specific case this was reported the
initial reporting of this was one of the
most horrific war crimes acts of Terror
of all
time okay and when it turns out it was
actually terrorists that killed their
own people then it doesn't matter
okay it doesn't matter when it was caus
mass
riots now or how about this you know
what now's not the time now's not the
time to talk about
it okay now's not the time to talk about
it and
today the Israeli government released
the GoPro footage from these Hamas
terrorists
who they had a press conference for
Foreign Press all to come watch the
clips because so many people are denying
what happened at this
point and the stuff that's described
there
is everything people said and worse
it's uh beheadings it's killing babies
burning babies murdering children
burning families
alive desecrating
corpses taking photos of you know dead
civilians taking their phone and sending
it to their family or posting it to
their
Facebook um and so I go listen I want to
tell the people who are talking about
Hamas like their freedom fighters and
revolutionaries or that like they they
actually were there just to get hostages
and most of them were were didn't want
to hurt
civilians I want to say hey guys listen
let's stop saying that because it's not
true you know what I mean it's let's not
let's not say
that and I get a huge response from
people saying how can you be so
insensitive you don't care about what's
happening in Gaza now is not the time
when is the
time when is it the
time to address
stuff incredibly harmful
misinformation when is it
okay and I'm not the thing is like the
way people I'm not denying I'm not
defending the IDF I'm not even I'm not
at all I've donated money I've supported
them on this show a lot more than I've
spoke about Israel I'll be
that's that's goddamn true for
sure but somehow it's never the time to
dispel this really
violent anti-semitic
rhetoric that's causing riots synagogue
leader over the weekend was stabbed and
killed so it's incredible to me that
people think I shouldn't care about
these
things because now's not the
time I believe that the time is good for
all all
spaces
of offering civilians your empathy your
caring your
understanding I don't believe that you
know I need to wait for you all to tell
me Now's the Time and whenever that is
probably never frankly probably
never here's some of the threads that
I've been seeing non-stop on my own
subreddit let's see here we go let's
take a look this is just sorting by
new uh it has a lot of up votes I don't
know
the exact number
but people are flocking here peace and
love someone take Ethan's phone away I
got to emphasize just how my stories
that I'm showing are
so you know it's so much not defending
the IDF it's literally just talking
about this anti-semitic violent
misinformation that continues to be
pedal and is having real consequences in
the
World I'll show you examples actually
before I get into it maybe that will
help to to tell you
guys how I don't think what I'm saying
should be controversial and if I do
think if you do think what I'm saying is
controversial I do think there's a
moment of introspective for yourself
where's that where's the album
love
I'll show you some of I'll show you
everything I've been posting over the
weekend so that you guys can judge for
yourself what kind of zionis pig
uh genocidal Maniac people go he's a
genocidal Maniac people go I cannot
watch I cannot support him anymore
here's the kind of stuff that I've been
uh storing about here is a tweet with
100,000 likes 14 million views she says
interesting what's interesting Jewish
people in the uh high levels of the
government now why is this
insane I said we should make them wear
little armbands so we can identify them
easier I saw even a lot of people saying
how is this
anti-semitic which alone is
concerning first of all all Jewish
people are not
Israeli all Jewish people do not support
the IDF I'm one of those people actually
believe it or
not and also Al one of the things you
often hear people say uh is like how you
know Zionism is not the same thing as
anti-Semitism a lot of people
who use the word Zionist like a slur
will say that and yet at the same time
they'll like this post that says
actually being Jewish is the same as
being Israeli uh so Zionism actually is
the same as just being Jewish do you see
why this is
insane okay
good here's another one this one I I
don't it probably has a lot more at the
time but 21,000 likes 2 million
views uh this this statement which has
literally no evidence to support it uh
meta is shadowbanning content that
supports Palestine according to
Palestinian accounts from Gaza and in
case anyone was wondering where Facebook
Instagram met a stand on the current
genocide of Palestine enacted by Israel
I don't know anything about that this is
just one person but the response was
Mark dot dot dot
Zuckerberg what do you think the
implication is there
guys that because Mark is
Jewish that he's going to
censor and defend I guess defend Zionism
defend Israel because he's Jewish and as
you guys know not all Jews are zionists
unless of course you
know only in memes in memes all Jews are
zionists but when I'm actually being
confronted on anti-Semitism then no
basically I'll have it both ways
please also said you know would be nice
maybe he should wear a nice little flare
around his arm as well Zuckerberg you
know so here's what it says this bombing
story's been driving me crazy
because I just think it's incredible
people say it doesn't matter when that
dominated the news cycle for a whole
day one of the worst war crime
acts of terrorism of all
time and people say it doesn't matter or
now's not the time this has been at this
point and it's more and more every day
the Associated Press the AP analyzed
more than a dozen videos from moments
before after and during as well as
satellite imagery and photos Associated
Press analysis shows that the rocket
that broke up in the air was fired from
within palestin Palestinian territory
and the hospital explosion was most
likely caused when a part of that rocket
crashed to the ground okay that's AP how
about
BBC I don't need to read all these you
read them all but they're basically all
saying that it
was
likely some outright just saying it was
blast this is Reuters you know these are
all pretty reputable I think blasted
Gaza hospital was not the result of an
Israeli missile strike but likely the
cause of a misfiring Palestinian rocket
the French military in uh intelligence
said about
it New York Times who was one of the
early offenders who wrote you know you
know these the really uh hysterical you
know headlines about 900 people dying
and hospitals being blown up Israel did
not bomb Gaza Strip Hospital said the
unclassified intelligence assessment
drafted on Wednesday we judge that
Israel was not responsible for an
explosion that killed hundreds of
civilians yesterday at the all AAL
Hospital in Gaza
Strip the United States has infrared
sensors which are both satellite and
aircraft based that can determine the
launch sites of a variety of rockets and
missiles that technology has proved
critical to the US assessment which does
not play blame place blame for the blast
on
Israel Wall Street
Journal uh says you
know experts say that Israel wasn't
responsible for the blast analysts say
it is unlikely to change the minds of
the Arab world which larges part the
Palestinians in the Hostile and are
hostile to Israel whatever that that
part see CNN I know it's not that
reliable uh as the other ones I I noted
but they also did their own forensic
analysis and said that the rocket came
from Gaza and not an air strike Politico
said the same thing NPR said the same
thing
um and you know it disturbs me that so
many people ran with this
headline from these sources these
sources citing them
and now when these same sources are
saying actually it wasn't it's probably
wasn't Israel it was almost certainly a
rocker a rocket from Gaza then all of a
sudden we don't care it's not the time
to talk about it it doesn't matter
doesn't
matter we don't care it's not credible
they're not credible really so people
who ran with the headline that Israel a
strike the hospital cited these exact
Publications now that they've put the
blame on Islamic Jihad these same
sources are not
credible
why does it matter when the IDF has
already confirmed killed thousands of
Palestinians again because I anticipated
it and people don't read what I write I
said and I'm I'm here saying yeah IDF
has killed thousands of Palestinians
horrific the bombing marked an enormous
escalation of the war risk bringing help
people in others the outrage caused by
this was felt globally and rightfully so
however truth matters and we must bear
in mind that while the IDF is not a
reputable source for news either is
Hamas once again who reported these Mass
casualties and this and the hospital
being exploded Health Ministry of Gaza
run by Hamas and that is
a fact you can look it up Health
Ministry of Gaza is run by
Hamas and just to be real when you see
the press conference at the uh the
disaster that happened at the hospital
you can see you know the doctors there
they're talking about how horrible it
was and right off the screen
there's photos of a Hamas dude with a
gun just making sure everyone's staying
in
line it's you have to you have to
understand
that Hamas and Israel are both going to
be participating in bad faith
propaganda
if you don't understand that and if you
believe everything Hamas
says then I don't believe that uh you
are the one that's being objective
actually I think you're being
deluded then I apologize you know I'm
sorry that I care about Israel and
Jewish people people go you're biased no
I'm
biased I lived there for 5 years my
wife's Israel my kids my wife's entire
family of course I have a bias nearly
everyone I love is affected by this if
you're incapable of understanding that
if this post enrages you then I'm afraid
you are nothing more than an unwitting
conduit of Hamas propaganda an
organization who stated goals to kill me
and my family now maybe that was a
little inflammatory to say that if
you're angry about these posts that you
are a uh conduit of Hamas propaganda but
technically it is true if you were
saying that the IDF blew up that
hospital and killed 900 people and then
now that it's basically uh
been revealed that that's not what
happened if you are a unwilling to
acknowledge that it was terrorists or B
saying that it doesn't matter let's move
on you are doing Hamas
propaganda maybe you're okay with that I
don't know but it is just a it's just a
fact um you know and if you ask me why
I'm not critical of Israel which
everybody's saying why I'm not crit
critical Israeli government then you
haven't been watching go watch the first
two and a half hours of our leftovers
episode episode if you if you think that
I don't know how to help you I don't
know what to say to you so I don't know
what exactly I've said to Warrant this
insane response of people saying that I
can't support you anymore they says I
can't support you
anymore because you care
about uh dispelling really
harmful and eventually anti-semitic
propaganda again I'm not even defending
IDF at all that's the crazy part Channel
4 and Al jaer did in my opinion really
silly videos trying to blame the
explosion on IDF neither of them relied
on analysis of impartial qualified
military demolition experts all the
Articles above site cited do people that
that is their expertise you know what I
mean impartial
expertise further disapproving Israel's
propaganda claim is not the same as
proving Israel caused the explosion
which I think is something a lot of
people misunderstood you might see
something that the IDF posted and say
like oh they removed the Tweet so
they're lying well the data that was
used from third party video satellite
footage geoca Etc none of that
information came from the IDF it's all
public
sourced here's some of the comments I
got in response to what I was saying and
yet he was running with the same
propaganda that Hamas was beheading
babies canceling my membership this is
really disappointing I said does it make
you feel better knowing that they were
sprayed with AK-47s instead as if that's
a more humane way to kill a
baby the videos are out again Israel
just did a they just did a press
conference putting out the GoPro videos
because they had to because people are
not
they're they're they're
on these civilians who were
murdered and saying now is not the time
to care about them
Hamas was
actually they were actually being pretty
pretty okay down there
again just just go see what
international reporters are
saying babies burned alive babies
murdered corpses
beheaded women raped people burned alive
little girl one of the videos it's a
little girl under a table by
herself hiding two terrorist walk in
talk for a moment and shoot her they
kill
her but now's not the
time when people are saying that didn't
happen they're saying that's a lie that
didn't even
happen there's a video of that if you
want to go watch
that all right I don't want to get
emotional give me a second
people are saying this didn't happen
that to me is
important and I think that there's now
is the time to talk about this and
everything and if you feel like I'm
overemphasizing the Israeli part listen
everyone in my periphery everyone in my
circle all the leftists uh people that I
watch that I'm part of that watch this
show because I consider myself part of
that side are
all pretty much
uncritically accepting of Hamas
propaganda and
unfuckingbelievable they go you know
burn burn them all to the ground they
have the right to defend themselves bomb
God like psycho
okay but on the left I don't see anyone
saying what I'm saying right now I just
see the opposite and so that's why I
feel that I need to say
it I don't if you're going to
extrapolate from this that I don't care
about Palestinians dying then you're
definitely reading way too far
into this and you're also in my opinion
really callous
here you go this is before the videos
were released this was
[Music]
uh I didn't even notice it
did I get
it I don't mean I don't
think yeah no you're right you're right
there was a there was like a charred
body there that I didn't even think
about oh thank God there was a chart so
can just here let me just scroll down
and I'll just read the top I was saying
this is this was been known since before
all these GoPro videos were released
today by the IDF but this organization
here just go ahead and read it for me
Dan can you erase that picture
love just read okay yeah so I'm just
going to read uh forensic Pathologists
and other experts from Israel and abroad
work at the national forensic pathology
Center in Tel Aviv to identify the
victims of October 7th here's what they
found and again this is even before the
GoPros when people are saying this stuff
didn't happen proportions of bodies we
received to our chart is high many have
gunshot wounds in their hands showing
they put up their hands uh to their face
in defense many were burned alive in
their their homes we know they were
burned alive because they're s in their
throats meaning they were still
breathing when set on
fire she also explains that the age of
victims ranged from 3 months to 80 or 90
years old many bodies including those of
babies are without
heads asked if they were
decapitated cougal the doctor answered
uh yes although it he admits that given
the circumstance it's hard to tell if
they were decapitated before after death
as well as how they were be beheaded if
it was from cutting or blowing it
off with a
RPG
so there's people who are really
obsessed over this 40 baby thing there's
babies without their
heads but if it makes you feel better
that they were just shot with
AK-47s and exploded their little
bodies then
uh I guess that I'm happy for you if
that that makes you feel
better wait what what the AB what
the did you show
that Oh I thought you said you removed
it oh okay my bad so everything
else after this is fine right okay cool
thanks here's another comment what is up
and this is response to everything I've
shown you guys up to now what is
upsetting to me is he completely
ignoring most people didn't get the idea
that the hospital was bombed by Hamas
but from the hospital itself to frame
believing the victims the Doctor's first
respond is the same as believing Hamas
propaganda is just inaccurate I think
what bothers people so much is that he
digs his heels into dispute any possible
misinformation against Israel but he
doesn't do any factchecking before
repeating anti-palestinian
misinformation it's frustrating
misinformation against Palestine is
infinitely more
harmful so I'm going to just say that
this person's
ignorant and you know I think a lot of
people are all too happy to not look too
deep into these things but again Gaza
Health Ministry is
Hamas so your comment is just ignorant I
don't know what else to tell you you you
just don't know what you're talking
about okay uh moving on here by the way
I was sharing another one the can
Canadian government put out an
independent analysis we are deeply
sanded by the loss of life at the
hospital in order to determine what
happened the Prime Minister asked me to
uh make a task force
with preparing an independent analysis
today I'm releasing as finding analysis
conducted independently by the Canadian
Forces intelligence command indicates
with a high degree of confidence that
Israel did not strike the
hospital the most likely scenario is
that the strike was caused by an errant
rocket fired from
Gaza if you need
more so far the only evidence that it
was Israel is that channel
4 put out a video
analyzing the phone call saying that it
was manipulated and then Al jazer saying
uh I don't even remember what they said
but it was all pretty silly in my
opinion so oh there was a few erased
tweets by by people in the government
and that's proof that it was Israel I
[Music]
guess
dude all right I'm going to
refresh hold
on it's gone right I just showed it
again so I just refreshed the
document
yeah
I think it's yeah it's
gone
um sorry I buttoned out again because I
showed that charred
body uh blah blah blah where was I I
don't know how much got cut off okay is
it it's after this one no it's gone okay
good so yeah this person said um that
I'm uh
spreading um
genocidal rhetoric I've had it with him
I'm spending genocidal rhetoric which
part of
this which part of
this
okay I shared this video which was
really sad and horrific I don't know if
the video's
here because it does matter to me I saw
this on Tik Tok actually let's let's
show it I mean let's pull it it shows a
before and after of their neighborhood
and Gaza it's horrific it's so sad
so
horrible how indiscriminate how
little the IDF cares about uh
casualties you
know uh here is an Israeli uh person who
left a message that they're disgusted by
my support of the Palestinians they says
here's an Israeli who no longer supports
because I donated 6,500 to Palestinian
charity guess I better choose a side
here's the translation dear friends
you're all wonderful but Ethan is simply
profoundly ignorant as an American who
moved here after years of experiencing
anti-Semitism is currently serving the
IDF I can no longer tolerate Ethan's
views without delving deep into the
matter and seeking the truth after 5
years I no longer follow them the money
I pay him every month goes to support
Palestine which will inevitably arrive
and fund
Hamas meanwhile I am hurting and have
lost three friends and another one who
has abducted Ed with her entire family
no one to this day knows what happened
to them I'm so sorry for your loss I
think it matters I actually do and I
think now is a perfect time to
acknowledge that and I'm very sorry that
happened to
you but uh I'm you know I'm standing my
by my convictions uh regardless of who
is going to piss off that's part of the
problem I'm having right now here's the
video that I
shared is this uh it has this really
beautiful song I don't know if
so so I'll just mute
it yeah so here you
know beautiful neighborhood actually it
looks really
nice and you know this is just
it's
crazy you know so I understand people
seeing these images I mean it's horrific
it's just
horrific
horrible senseless sad
tragic this is the stuff I started
posting this morning that I guess caused
a new flurry of people to get so angry
at me that they said take Ethan's phone
away they
said now I really want you to listen
this is the stuff I shared that really
pissed people
off I said please at least stop calling
Hamas Freedom Fighters I don't think
that's asking for a lot although I
understand now is not the
time uh this guy said I saw an
Indescribable raw footage of fas
Massacre along with hundred other
International
journalists here's what I saw Hamas
Terror screaming alakar as he
frantically beheaded a dead man with a
shovel it's reported by other uh
journalists that he was alive at the
time
but doesn't really matter does it uh two
sons are screaming from for their dad
saying they're going to die amas terce
casually and calmly takes a bottle of
water from the family's fridge and
drinks it as the two boys weep amas
terce enter a house where a small girl
is seen hiding under the table after
some talking back and forth they shoot
and kill her as she hides under the
table it's hard to say how old she is
she's seven and nine years old a moss
terrorist setting fire to a house in a
kabut a beheaded Israeli soldier photo
of a dead baby and a child burned beyond
recognition scores of dead people on the
road after a moss executed them in their
cars yelling Allah abbar AOS terrorist
calling his parents I killed 10 Jews
with my own hands I'm using the dead
Jewish woman's phone to call you now the
mother says may God protect to so many
more scenes but I hope you get the gist
the authorities asked not to film it out
of respect for the
relatives uh there's other reporters
with other really horrific accounts too
much to share and too horrific frankly
to continue to read is it so is now not
the time I just I genuinely Wonder
now is not the time to care that people
are saying this didn't
happen am I not allowed to care about
this I'm only allowed to care about
Palestinian civilian deaths not allowed
to care about these
people that's what you're saying I
think you know I got mad I said
look how dumb you look hos
apologist and I quoted specifically the
one of the little girl that was murdered
while
hiding here's another one oh no this is
the same
[Music]
one this is a story that's been running
uh you know and I says listen this is
it's there was a massive round of
bombing last night apparently in
Northern Gaza and at least BBC T BBC and
this is a breaking headline they're at
least now after the last time at least
you know giving important context that
ham run Ministry says 436 people were
killed I'm not even disputing those
numbers because by all C there was mass
bombing there that was horrific and
terrifying and just
wanting uh disregard for civilian
lives said I'm MN the constant tragic
loss of life in Gaza there has been so
much civilian death it's
heartbreaking this is another reporter
with there images are put up of the
burned babies so small you could cradle
them in the crook of your arm a
journalist who is also a parent tells me
the blanket was a swaddle it's given to
babies who are either newborn or close
to
it there are many broader issues around
occupation and the need for humanitarian
assistance and
proportionality Israel must do
everything to protect filings of Gaza
but what I saw today has nothing to do
with resistance it was all about wanting
to kill
Jews if you don't believe me go watch
the videos
so this is it this is what I said this
this is what I posted
today now now look at the reactions I'm
getting and I guess maybe I'm
crazy maybe I am genocidal against
Palestinians for caring about this
stuff um I must be here's this this is
the post is getting lots of uh
likes I'm going to be calm here let me
go to the page cuz here you can see the
amount of likes it's getting here it is
oh can you see the likes I it doesn't
show uh here I can show my
phone actually I can't tell if it was it
says
22 I guess I got a lot of down votes now
since I'm covering it on the show but I
think a lot of these people are briting
from other communities too
probably including by the
way
Hassan's Discord which is not associated
with him he's not in there he has
nothing to do with it but the people in
there oh it's at 550 up votes okay great
so 500 so there's lots of people coming
here saying that I shouldn't be talking
about this and I'll read it the s's
Discord and by the
way to the people who are in that
Discord I saw everything you guys said
it was recorded sent to me the during
our our uh whole
episode on the Gaza Israel conflict what
I saw in that Discord was Universal near
Universal praise for
Hamas near Universal saying people
deserved it near Universal people saying
dudes who was like the hang gliders came
in and showed him what's up people
saying he's spitting facts near
Universal people near universally
calling me a Zionist Pig Mass
murdering genocidal
freak and if you want to know the truth
that me up seeing that
Discord because it made me realize
that a lot of these people are watching
this show and it frankly Disturbed me
and I want to make it clear Hassan
doesn't support that stuff I had a
private conversation with him and I told
him like this stuff is really upsetting
to see and Hanan sat down with his mods
and he sat down with his team and said
this stuff's not acceptable so again
it's important to emphasize he is not
responsible for this but I will
say that seeing
that oh and here just again
to just speak well of my friend he
posted this same post I did and says
it's straight UPS anti-semitic uh which
it obviously
is
so so the reason that I cancelled the
show on Friday frankly is because I read
that
Discord um and it
was I don't know what's the word but
frankly it
was I don't know what's the word I mean
was I was horrified I was
felt I felt used in a sense that these
people were watching this and like they
didn't actually care at all they saw me
as like a vessel to
spread what they believe is true they
don't care about what I'm saying at all
they're not listening in fact they
hate me they hate
me um it it was it was
I couldn't do the show on Friday I was
so upset by it I I just I don't even
know how to express it I don't know how
to express it I guess you just have to
go read
it but I was like man these
are this is pretty heavy
man and so that that hit me hard as hard
as anything and I was really up
from
that and so a lot I do think a lot of
these people are bading from these types
of
communities but I do think there's a lot
of people in this community because
listen I've been doing a show a leftist
show for over a year now I have leftist
politics I follow leftist shows I do
think there's a lot of people in this
community who feel that now is NE the
time not never these people right I I've
expressed myself I don't need to repeat
but these kinds of people so let me read
this peace and love someone take Ethan's
phone away 550 people came and like this
post the Israeli citizens who died or
injured on October 7th attacks deserve
empathy of course but Ethan
posting an entire threat of horrible
things that happened to them followed by
a post that basically says and what's
happening in Gazo is also horrible
talking about war crimes and a little e
a literal ethnic cleansing is just so
toned deaf they said so they says the
Israelis deserve empathy of course but
just not right
now not right now they don't now's not
the time it doesn't matter that there's
tons of people lying and saying it never
happened people saying that Hamas is
actually they're actually nicer than you
would think they're actually not that
bad
um despite all
that now is not the time to express
empathy for 1300 slain civilians we
don't you know now's another time I also
find it interesting they says you
know they go and what's happening in
Gaza is also horrible like if I don't
say anything then they say he didn't
post anything about Gaza if I do
say anything then it's like he didn't
say
enough now is not the damn time to talk
about slain Israeli citizens who death
are being
forgotten
and
minimized I understand Ethan feels more
connected to Israel because he lived
there but I think he should take a step
back and really think he needs to take a
step back and think about how he'd view
what's going on if he had no ties to
Israel honestly I don't even think he'd
be this defensive if it were America
doing the same thing as Israel what am I
defensive about
exactly
people lying that Hamas
killed babies and
kids in Cold Blood beheaded burned
alive uh yes I get defensive when people
say that didn't happen is that a problem
do I get defensive when people say that
Israel is doing wanton Massacre of
civili of Palestinian civilians no I do
not get defensive about that in fact I
age with that I've said it a
lot in no uncertain terms I've said it
so much so that you've seen Israeli fans
now are turning against me so you say
uh you say I wouldn't care if I wasn't I
like to believe that I would
care I'd like to believe that I would
care and I think that people who don't
live in Israel should care as
well you said at the beginning of this
that uh they deserve empathy but at the
same time you say not now and also stop
getting defensive about
them I don't think Ethan is apathetic to
Palestinian suffering but I feel like he
really cannot see this clearly and
objectively
again speaking up for the dead
Palestinian or the dead Israeli
civilians somehow in so many people's
minds is equated to defending the IDF
which is insanely
crazy
you say the speaking up for the slain
civilians is the same as supporting the
IDF that's insane I mean that's that's
up you should really think about
that think about
that seems like he traded in Twitter for
Instagram stories that's top comment
that's fair
enough uh also by the way I'll read the
last one she says Ethan if you see this
I'm a fan I know you're not trying to be
cruel I just think you should take a
step back please don't post this to your
story oh well you posted this this
thread is getting a lot of traction so
but they said this isn't a hate post
just food for thought okay I mean listen
I appreciate that they didn't come out
so hot although can't say it he's clear
hurting bad right now but he needs to
get off the internet it's affecting
him okay this is about I posted about
Treader it's just not good get offline
so I mean who who's saying this to
people that care about the who are just
you
know are you saying this to Hassan are
you telling him to get off the
internet because he's hey you're you're
you're obsessing dude it's time to get
off the
internet I don't think you guys
understand what it means to look at the
mass murder of Jews and say it didn't
happen to say it was
exaggerated I'm ready to skip the live
if he goes into another uh hourong
unchallenged
rant I have no problem hearing his
opinions as much as I'm disagreeing with
a lot of the Nuance but the place for
that is left over someone else giving
additional options his rants during the
other EPS end up being screaming at chat
and the crew just sitting in silence
fair enough I
guess uh Ethan is someone who needs
incredible amount of validation his
opinion feel like it's solid this is
incredibly nuanced discussion and he
will never get the total validation he's
looking for that's why he won't stop
talking about
it
um literally
only all I've ever done since the
beginning of this is advocate for
civilians that's
it the disagreements I had with Hassan
and our original one was literally just
trying to get some crumb of
empathy and that's the same as wanting
to kill every Palestinian how is that
possible how can how can so many people
be drawing that
conclusion he gets all of his info from
Twitter which is not great I don't know
what that even means I've been reading
non-stop articles I literally posted
headlines to every major news
article I'm skipping H3 for a while
that's fine
understand uh but essentially there's
been a this you know what I'll be honest
a lot of people in this thread aren't
being super
nasty um and it's fine I I think it's
totally fine for the them to share their
their opinions on it however I will say
that there are certain assumptions being
made here that are
really so
unfair that I need to get off because
I'm being
emotional or that I need to uh not now
not now is not the
time as almost three years as a member
I've canceled my membership for now I
think I'll come back eventually but it
feels like he's just trying to dunk on
anyone who doesn't agree with him 100%
people are dead families are destroyed
and Ethan is bragging about being
right I'll stay sub for now okay I
appreciate
that I can't keep paying to see him post
so callously how is it callous how is it
callous how is it callous what I posted
I I
really advocating for dead civilians for
truth is
callous
I don't need to keep reading but
whatever you
know
um there's another one that was getting
lots of
points Ethan please understand Ethan's
bias towards Israel but to use your
platform over and over again to promote
the same narrative that most mainstream
media have been Pro promoting since this
started I just don't
understand I think Ethan should step
away from the topic for a while and
really reflect about how he's gone about
this mods will remove this pulse they
keep removing it it's not cool stop
censoring
us uh you know I'm trying to be calm and
I'm coming out here and I'm expressing
myself as honestly and sincerely as I
possibly can if I if if these posts
enraged you I hope I've explained it in
such a way that you can at least maybe
understand why you might be coming off
his
callous why you might be coming off is
uncaring and how that is upsetting me
when I see
that because like
listen everybody wants their side to be
perfect villains or perfect monsters
that's that's what I get out of
this
that that that's really what I get out
of
this you
know people say I'm silencing you guys
so I don't know if anyone wants to say
anything all
right what speak I feel like it's a it's
a conversation that's better for someone
like you and H to have
together I don't know if I'm properly
equipped to uh give my side in the
correct way can I advocate for you for a
minute
M the people who are saying AB needs to
respond AB needs to speak up are
you guys I'm not going to say I'll say
it you don't have to say anything and
I'm not I'm not speaking for ab this is
my opinion
who the are you to demand him to
talk about
something I appreciate that let him
process it and feel what he
wants without
your expectations and coming
down on him from all different
angles how dare
you oh here was my favorite one actually
excuse me meat and beef turkey I didn't
know what this means but
apparently Israel state funded ads on
the
podcast I don't know what this even
means this explains why certain channels
can monetize videos on sensitive topics
While others get demonetized YouTubers
do not have direct control over which
ads are shown on their videos
advertisers determine where the ads are
placed and what kind of channels they
advertise on YouTubers can block
specific ads but do not not have the
freedom to select
ads
Israel state funded ads on the
podcast have has anyone ever seen an
Israel ad on the
podcast is thiser is this a
um is this anti-semitic or
no I mean I think it's just stupid a lot
of stuff goes to I mean a lot of funding
goes to Israel you know and a lot of
you know shap
Bond uh Investments whether it be your
University or what you buy every day so
it's wait they're trying to defend me
how do you read
that which one this post I think wait
how I don't understand it because there
was some other post where somebody said
they got an Israeli ad on the podcast
about the war okay okay and they were
pointing out that you have no control
over that got it they someone said I
knew right after this there would be
another
thread so wait I didn't see that
one I I because of that comment I went
looking for it it it didn't even have
any up votes it was somebody saying they
got an ad from Israeli like now's the
perfect time to visit guys fly to
beautiful Israel I don't think it was a
tourist ad I saw the there was like a
video oh I did see one that was so
crazy and weird I remember that I don't
think it's ever run on our Channel there
I think there was a post from last week
or two weeks ago that I'll try to find
it I don't have the ability to turn
those off but I saw that and it was
crazy yeah it was like this
could be your kid you should pull it up
I'm actually curious to watch it I
remember what it was it was like your
kid won't understand this but D yeah it
was really
brutal just like dude what are you doing
who's this is not going to help at
all and
so this is my perspective this is the
pain that I'm
experiencing no so many of
my contemporaries people on the left
fans of this
show I feel are
callously discre
callously saying now is not the time and
also accusing me of being genocidal
insensitive for speaking about something
that's important to me and I hope I've
explained to you guys and it why I think
it is
important and
how this this whole thing is just so
unfair I'm sorry it's just it's so
unfair and I'm not getting angry that's
just my opinion that's all
that's all I can do I'm not going to
stop talking about it why should
I all I'm saying is that Israeli
civilians died if that offend
you
if that offends
then you might be
lost you might be
lost did you find
it I doubt we'll find it it was a while
the ad I I Googled around a little bit
but I I have not seen it remember
there's a rainbow in it or some
yeah it's very
weird oh wait I I think I found
it yeah that was
it this yeah
real there is this the one oh nice dude
this is so the weird the the way they
did it all like it's so up hold
on so this was run as a ad for
sure I don't know if it was this video
but the red PST I saw was alleging that
this run us an it I believe it oh I I've
seen this as a yes this is the same
thing so hold on let me read it for
audio listeners it's a picture of like a
rainbow and beautiful almost like
Heavenly uh My Little Pony
Vibes we know that your child cannot
read this we have an important message
to tell you as parents 40 infants were
murdered in Israel Jesus Christ by the
Hamas terrorists he say Hamas
Isis yeah I don't know where that's not
just as you would do everything for your
child we will do everything to protect
ours now now hug your baby and stand
with us now I'll say this is
crazy protecting your children bombing
indiscriminate bombing of Gaza is has
nothing to do with protecting your kids
in fact I think there's a good argument
to say it makes them less safe in
fact the I don't know what else I can
say about it I mean if at this point if
you don't understand my perspective then
I just I don't know if there's just
there's never going to be a bridge
between us on this
topic and if that's too much for you
then I invite you to go listen to other
shows that will Echo your beliefs 100%
and you won't ever have to feel
uncomfortable
again
truly that's
it you can turn chat back
on
okay I don't ever come in here planning
to do this by the way it's just you know
these are things I have to
say I have to say
it what happened should have happened
what should have happen happen and it is
what it is well
said hold on hold on hold on what does
what does uh Babel what is his theory on
this whole
thing that's
it you are touching your eyes a lot
because ah I'm trying to rub it in no
you rubbed it in an hour ago nice try
you stressed right now I am stressed man
he's flaring up right now I am flaring
up bro chill I'm stressed look stupid
all right who side are you on are you on
Hamas or or IDF choose a
side maybe that means squeaky
floor it's hard to it's hard to decipher
that oh my God Jes dud get that out of
here I don't like that did you show that
on screen you did not show that on
screen okay good that's way too violent
what it just looks it's Indiana Jones I
know you can't show that dude
YouTube's crazy that looks insane did
look really disgusting that's I think
that's anti-semitic of YouTube to not
let us show that that's a Nazi having
his face
melted that scared me a little bit have
you never seen Indiana Jones I have when
I was really young but I that was before
I was conscious okay the way that was
edited made it look especially yes P
I'll post it on Twitter I got no maybe
not I got to add more Lube because my
the sides of my eyes feel super dry and
do you think it could be stress related
H who knows I think it could definitely
exacerbate it yeah for sure you know the
other thing I got to say I I didn't want
to I didn't want to make it about me but
the last couple days I've been having
something like around
my I swear to God you know what it was
Dan I think it was the Butterfly Kisses
we were doing the other day oh yeah
it might have passed wait lupus is
contagious yeah L yeah I think I caught
lupus from you dude
have to use protection next time I just
started putting some lotion on it
yesterday and hopefully it'll relieve
itself Jesus Christ man damn thank you I
can't wait to put it on you someone said
it's
Derma I it was some kind of dermatitis
I don't know I don't know what
those people are saying to me long
clinical names and but to everyone
else who's you
know able to watch this something that I
do think is very
important and just to be open-minded and
hear me out is you know all I could ask
for and I am trying my absolute best to
uh lend the same
empathy to everybody thank
you so who's going to take my phone away
who's going to come get it I dare you
come get it now put that phone down for
my dead cold
hands thank
[Music]
you all right well we have a fun episode
today believe it or
not lots of stuff to get
[Applause]
to you know what you're doing right now
I know I
know I unsubscribed I can't listen to
him
anymore just so you guys know time
stamps are up literally 5 minutes after
the podcast ends or like the live stream
ends so if you're just skip it just so
you know time stamps are up the second
so if you're like can't listen to it you
know you can skip it easy just saying
literally babies are being murdered
right now and yesterday and the day
before you are not what Ethan that's the
point right now's not the
time now is not the
time
exactly all right let's let's move on so
let's see here um idubz just posted a
video that I think you're going to want
to see really yeah it's a he said
content cop
Israel yo
Israel that's going to be an interesting
uh International international criminal
cont let's pull it up let's pull up cont
he's content comping a country yeah he's
going hard this time he really uh upped
his upped his Focus
mhm
I sent it did you get it gen genuinely
if you read this stuff and get outraged
then I genuinely think
that yeah you're probably right you
shouldn't watch I think at least for now
you know what I mean get the out
did you send me the link
uhhuh all right let's see item's my
friend so I'm going to watch this and I
know he's okay with it so shut
up wait this he changed the title it
should I should be able to flush paper
towels yeah oh you got me good
bro oh you believe it yes and I thought
I was like oh maybe he changed the title
as a gag I should be able to flush paper
towels I this I'm goddamn right
dude I oh this is a idb's
complains I be I was ready for is real
hun for it you thought they were serious
I was like you know maybe it's an
interesting it's an interesting angle
coner is isra it's crazy dude how did I
know I don't know such insane taste
Israel I mean they are
up you got that
right all right Israel what's his point
we don't I mean watch someone watch this
and tell me if he agrees or disagrees or
if I'm if it seems like he thinks you
should be able to from title so thank
you bro he's obviously been watching the
show I guess
so the lupus man what is this I love
this
one who's the L who is this isn't that
Batman it's Batman oh the lupus man
okay cuz you have like the makeup
instead of instead of super strength and
power I am sick tired
and around my
eyes so here we've been talking a big
debates about the dishwasher ultimate
test and uh we got big plans for that on
Wednesday we've been dis yeah we're
going to get scientific with it but this
to me this is this is a
really good test cuz this is pushing it
to the Limit yeah oh why did that
happen I hadn't seen this one I'm going
to go ahead and say I would expect that
not to work I don't know that's even as
a defender of the no prein cuz when it's
like I mean yeah like dried out pea soup
that's like concrete so let's see so
here it is the uh before the before he
got the prein he got the holes wow
here's
after is that you know what I can't tell
I can't tell if it's I don't think
that's residue I think scraping but I
think it's clean y oh all right what did
they say he said sat out for a little
over 5 hours placed in the dishwasher on
its own with one of the shown pods
results
spotless wait they they also you they
didn't even do the prein and it's still
got it all
spotless Talent you Talent
y holy that one is pretty
compelling oh um Talent you I'm telling
you yeah I
mean that D PE soup is not easy to
scrape off you know there's been a lot
of conflicting uh point of views though
and and I've seen people are like listen
you have to preent it's just not
sanitary it's not good for the washer
it's not clean there's lots of opinions
on
[Music]
this but
uh listen the proof is in the split pie
soup there here's another debate going
on on the subreddit do not send infab
brand to fist Fest people are
saying a lot of people are saying that
please please do not send almost 3,000
now yeah that's that's quite a lot of
people who
fting don't love that idea please do not
send infr brand to go to fist Fest yes I
get the people who throw fist wear are
aware and that it's absurd and a bit
cheeky but it is very clear a positive
and freeing event for them infer Brand's
whole shtick is to make strangers feel
uncomfortable and sketched out I mean
that's that's true I feel like they have
a point they do have a point you
probably don't want to hear that but I
read this and said
no I had the same I had the same
reaction the exact opposite of how
people who are trying to go to this
field plus it's obviously a very gay
event messing with a bunch of them is
like YouTube prank mindset it's not
messing with them I'm there to document
the but I guess I see what you mean
maybe we'll send someone who's like a
that's what I was going to say is like
if we could do it in a way that the goal
isn't to be weird to people I think INF
is maybe the wrong tool for the job yes
I agree I see I see I see the point you
guys are making here and I I agree we
need to send an empath to fist Fest
Shane Dawson available I think so you
want to go Olivia you think yeah the
office empath I would love to go to fist
Fest I think that I could make some
friends would anyone volunteer I mean I
if you really want someone to go I would
oh my
God no I would love to go that would be
so iconic oh I mean someone would
have to go with me I will not go alone
well you be like a camera person exactly
I will interesting oh wait where is it
did we know where it is it's in Florida
Georgia GE
Georgia oh my God this was my ass I
didn't expect it to be in Georgia it's
in Georgia what the is Georgia
Sam's from Georgia yeah I know Sam could
show me around samam are you here no she
had to go home you think she'd be up for
that even or
no I think she could she does love going
home right it's interesting she might
not not want to do it but the free trip
back home you and Sam going would be so
awesome I love that okay let's
see if she's interested interesting now
this is an idea now we're talking we're
talking now we're
talking we would be very gentle very
sweet just there to document just there
to learn observe educate appreciate
absolutely so where did we send infra BR
maybe some like weird rightwing party oh
Sam just said she love to go to this
is oh man I'm so
excited all right girly
strip we have to we have to have like
the okay from from the fist Fest uh
leadership first of all whoever you know
what I mean like yeah of course of
course can you Zach you're in touch with
Hunger right I am yes so ask him just
tell them about our plan with the girls
and that we're Cur we love the event we
think it's interesting and we just want
to document it okay you got it um I'm
trying to I'm looking on we can just do
audio too which is you know a lot of
them may not want to be put their faces
on
camera right or just censor people
unless we get releases from them that
it's you know okay well obviously I
can't show participating right yeah
there's probably I mean there'll
probably good moments for interviews
outside of the Arena you know so I looks
like there's three events in 2024
there's spring F fling two fs and then
there's full moon with two fs and then
there's October fist Fest next October
not this October already passed or is it
happen 2020 2024 so let's ask an
upcoming thing okay let's ask maybe he
he prefers one or maybe they have
different management they're cool we
figure it out this is uh someone said
send infr brand to RFK Junior rally
that's an idea oh my God any
conservative rally would be so good so
good so so so so good I love that it is
interesting yeah um yeah this this looks
like a this looks interesting all right
exciting yeah so reach out please Zach
you got it but okay good advice thank
you to the subred for that
one
look at these guys this whole geog
guessing thing is turned
into such a phenomenon and I have to say
it is pretty interesting these guys and
gals are so dang good at it I I think I
can guess here is the Esports uh
championship of geog guessing check it
out no way we're on the first round wait
it's coming down game five NZ n npz
round six oh my God we are in Russia
we're in Russia is this where it all
ends it has to end here it could not cuz
this looks like
sir how do they know that in all know
it's Russia cuz they're they're geog
guessers bro they can tell I you know
I've done the geoguesser thing but like
there's the one mode where it just does
like cities so you have like lots of uh
context clues of like the license plates
and the languages on the wall and like I
I pretty decent at that this how
the do you look at this for 2
seconds and say oh yeah Russia so I've
did I've listened to their explanations
it's usually like their roads are they
like this center line or these arrows or
you know this kind of dirt on the side
or something like that you know or like
the way that the that the electric poles
look or a certain color of the electric
Pole or something they have they have
little yeah I guess it makes sense they
got little somethings for everything I
need to get out of I mean that isn't
that scarier for cons he need to be
pinpoint accur he has to he has to line
the road up here and and dude fungus is
not happy with this round they have to
put a pin on Earth he's looking for
it just you have to guess this is both
you have to guess sand and fungus I mean
con knows this as well they're both
looking in the same
area it comes down to who can line up
the road this Road's going slightly East
West it looks like yeah another thing
they do is they can tell where the sun
is and then what Atmos or what
hemisphere it's in based on where the
sun is sh no how could you couldn't do
that unless you knew like what time day
it was they do it she he just said
listen what he just said cuz it would
matter like what month of the year the
photo was taken it was listen okay who
can line up the road this Road's going
slightly East West how does he know that
how does he know that well that I guess
you could tell from the position of the
sun
yeah if you know what you're if it's
behind or in front in front or behind
the road it would have to be either East
West because the sun moves in an East
West Direction what year they know
everything like taking his time again
now again it's just he's an impossible
man to read fungus obviously always
looks still manages it there's pressure
now does he know get a guess
then where this is it this is it this is
it is it going to take it 5
Seconds oh my God everything is on him
he's
come on dud that is
close they did it right next to each
other and then so I guess the loser
takes that's
outrageous he does it wow 2,000 damage
in the end and you get out in
Russia congratulations on your $100 gift
certificate to applebe I don't know just
because it's not a big sport I don't
know oh people are saying there was a oh
there's a compass okay well then that
makes it pretty easy certainly that
would explain yes that would be
helpful that makes it a lot easier
doesn't it
um I liked our method our method made
sense too love yeah I also want to say I
have to give a special shout out I asked
somebody in the audience who had nothing
to do this weekend to to transcribe the
preachers um the Sean PR full monologue
and they did it lovely so here's what
I'm hoping to do if we can play it and
I'll try to
do it with
him not secretly getting by sleep on the
sofa sleep in the bed you want a woman
let go mad do the Holy Ghost to to all
them boys they be wild and no good you
know what call him wait hold on hold on
okay ready is this you want to take it
from the
top I'm assuming this is from the top
what's the first thing Play No secretary
be getting mad no secretary be get mad
there it is okay all right fair enough 3
2 1 go no no there getting mad sleep on
the sofa you sleep on the bed
you get mad we just do the Holy Ghost
them boys they wild out for no good you
know
good some of them are
chosen
impressive he told
the no
good I can do the whole thing but
but it's pretty long harder to listen
than
Hamas Israel it's up there it's three
minutes of
this the man is impressive I always say
30 feet
of with 37
of he hits that he has like different
tones in it
too
oh man this tickled me on
Reddit somebody God dang it I keep
posting the closing the
browser because of my dang
text let me go back and open it again
you guys it's rewind
time somebody posted this to I'm the
main character
subreddit which is a subreddit
where uh I get
gu people who are think they're the main
character be um ridiculed by the
internet and so somebody posted this
video of
me 3,000 uploads too wow here it is
check this out you remember this video
guys oh yeah hey guys you guys know who
I
[Music]
am all right cool well take
care dude what the first of all I'm
very proud of this video and
how I was making fun of the rock I don't
know if you guys remember he did this
video where he went up to a tour bus
like that in Beverly Hills or somewhere
and was like what's up
guys and everyone's like the rock oh my
God and so I
knew I was like please I hope nobody
knows who I am on this bus please please
please please hey guys you guys
know who I
am
all right cool well take care no it's a
joke you
morons no all right there's some people
thank you the top comment is family he
did this after the rock but the the fact
that this was on I'm the main character
is pretty
astonishing I heard this guy smoked
crack once that's
true this is clearly a joke how rder is
the first one to try to make fun of
people but the last to get a joke thank
you love that for you uh Brown Magic
good redditors are wild I used to say in
general man it's a
whole I used to be a commenter and stuff
like 10 years ago but I don't know
there's there's a certain time in your
life where I feel like you got to stop
leaving comments on Reddit do you know
what I mean like I still I go to the
chat I I enjoy reading the comments
occasionally to get a sense of things
but leaving a comment on
Reddit I still stand by what I I say
about redddit what did you say about
Reddit I think the inter that website
needs to be taken down from the face of
the Earth yeah wow you also said that
about you said that about our Reddit you
but you think that about the whole
Reddit I think the whole Reddit yeah I
think it's just the vile evil
cess pool of is that personal
uh because of the personal grief you've
taken there or other it's a mix yeah a
mix yeah it's a vendetta what do we do
about it just just get rid of it
what's your plan let's do it I don't my
my plan is to be elected president and
that's I'm going to take that off of the
executive order well I don't know about
you but I don't wait for the revolution
the revolution happens now and whatever
happens
happens I can say that right Dan it's a
joke I didn't say anything just I'm I'm
Pro Revolution you know go proud of the
people I'll see you on Reddit there's a
fun game I play where I
make uh violent
death threats and cheeky ways to try to
get you know I not that that's what I
did now right of course not but it is a
fun game to play on the
internet something I would never partake
in
clearly uh did it game you win often say
what did it game you win
often uh I my record is uh I don't play
this
game all all I was trying to say was it
just needs to be uh
handled in a very U positive way and
Manner and uh you know uh taken with
legal action legal action okay good
distinction I
agree yeah to answer your I lose some
and I win some Olivia I lose some yeah
I'll accept that absolutely uh let's see
you're a loser oh I wanted to kind of
get your guys' take on this I thought it
was real interesting I don't know if
this specific one is good but I've
seen these types of videos where a
couple decides if something said is
cheating or
not and I find myself kind of surprised
by some of their answers and I'm just
kind of curious like I'm cheating
right I'm curious what you all think um
because I thought it was kind of a
universal understanding of what cheating
is and
isn't but it really isn't where did that
link go
here
all
right so again I don't know who these
people are I just saw it on my real page
but I'll give them a shout out because
it's their it's real real
Alexandra she's so real right
now all right here we go so cheating not
cheating or not cheating let's go do you
think it's cheating if your partner
still has dating apps but doesn't
actively use them they both said not
cheating I mean it's not not technically
cheating but it's also weird that's s
like you should not you should erase
that yeah right and by the way she and I
got I'm a little concerned cuz she was
like that's so me did you notice she did
that well I'm wondering I mean some
people play Tinder like that's a fun
thing but also maybe what's that mean
play Tinder if you you and your girlies
are like let's swipe you know it's just
the thing is listen if I'm dating a girl
who's playing Twitter or whatever it's
this is a place where you go to meet
people right right it's a dating site
right I think the fact that they're
acknowledging it means that they're
aware that it's still on their phone and
if they are that's weird just erase it
how hard is it to erase an app my for
you page yeah I'm not I'm not looking I
don't need this app so I would say it's
not it's not cheating obviously but it
is making me uncomfortable so I would
put my finger in the middle on this one
like I'm cheating right can we do polls
Dan I actually am curious what the
audience feel on this one
too yeah yeah let's get to the bottom of
this you
know at the top comment on idb's video
idbs really made an entire video just to
defend
Ethan thank you man somebody's speaking
up for me finally I love him I love Ian
I love Ana thank God man God
damn great
people all right let's see what what do
you guys think with the app I got to
pull it off and I I've considered my
myself someone that's not jealous or
possessive at all I feel like my takes
on cheating is really
reasonable but you know fing in the
middle on this you
know why have
it so we got should I add a third option
like
sus Yeah well yeah it's maybe not
cheating cheating it's attempting to
cheat what what's a good word for it
sus sus yeah sus yeah I threw it up okay
it's
sus it's just a little bit well I guess
I would say
it's it's sussy sussy that's where you
would go to cheat you know right yeah so
everyone most people are saying sus some
people are saying
cheating cheating is a little extreme
because that's like oh I caught you like
having sex or like cooking up with
someone you know yeah I think a lot of
people have different not true but let's
get on top of this
yeah all right
next yeah do you think it's cheating if
your partner sleeps in the same bed as
someone else but doesn't kiss them do
you think it's what hold the
phone on that one when does that happen
sleep in the same bed as someone but
don't kiss them are you talking about
like your brother are you talking about
like opposite sex what the that's
weird why are you both cheating on
that that's the weird as
what what is what is the circumstance
that that leads to that happening well
I'm assuming it excludes like
family right because that would just be
yeah obviously stupid obviously not
your
brother at least I don't so I don't know
what goes down there and Alabama I know
out here in California I'm trying to
figure out like a scenario maybe like if
if one of them was at a party and got
like super drunk and then like crashed
at a house and if there was someone else
in the bed too okay that would I would
not be okay with that you would not if
my significant other went out drinking
without
me and then slept
in uh a man's bed all
night I was like we didn't do anything I
just slept there I would be very
uncomfortable with that MH very
uncomfortable with
that like I wouldn't do that I wouldn't
do that I wouldn't sleep in the bed with
somebody else what if he's your friend
though what if he's their friend her
friend it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter then you know you know what you
know what's happening M
it's no anyone got thoughts same exact
same thought like I would sleep you go
you know I'll sleep on the floor I'll
sleep on the couch you know what I mean
like I don't know
man it's just way too close it's way too
close to cheating sleeping in the same
damn bed it is weird and it's also like
you need to go around to like explain
why that could happen also what were you
wearing you in your you know you mean
yeah you wearing your jeans or did you
take your jeans off to get a little cozy
most people don't sleeping their
jeans what were you
wearing what do you what do you think
Dan you mean you're
laughing no yeah I agree with you I mean
I like I was saying was like more just
confused about the scenario that would
that would lead to that happening I mean
the only one the only way that the
scenario makes sense it have to be like
a drinking night or like a work trip or
something you know what I
mean so I I I'm concerned about this
couple I concerned about you guys
cheating if your partner likes another
person's bikini picture do you think
it's cheating okay okay liking another
person's bikini picture
now obviously it's not cheating but and
it I think dudes who go on Instagram and
like like these bikini models and
it's just it's just
so it's not cheating right cuz they
don't necessarily know them or maybe
they do I don't know it makes me it sus
it sus I the way I've always felt that
is like I'm not allowed to be mad at you
for doing that but like I'll see it and
be like it's disrespectful yeah ex it
just it's like oh you not going to make
you feel good it's not you know what I
mean cuz that like might as well not
happen that like doesn't mean and like
it right right the act of liking it is
almost
like you're you're reaching out to them
kind of here I'm here you don't have to
like it you don't have to like it that
is true yeah it's just uncalled for come
up reach in pool like obviously it's not
cheating but it is very disrespectful
yeah you know what I
mean thank you if your partner goes out
with someone else with the opposite sex
even though they're friends but doesn't
tell you about it do you think it's
cheating if your partner is texting
someone else on Instagram do you think
it's wait she didn't answer that one
dude I'm worried the she said so
the question was if you go out drinking
with a member of the opposite sex in
this case you know if you're
heterosexual and don't tell your partner
is that cheating uh that's pretty weird
that is literally cheating in my
opinion that's crazy like just the two
of them that's a
date and she didn't want to answer that
dude
bro it's cheating if you found out your
partner was flirting with someone else
but nothing happened do you think it's
what do you mean flirting that that's
too open-ended I don't know what that
means she doesn't either she went with
she yeah
flirting boy you got to have a convo
with your
girl cheating if your partner hides
their friend from you and doesn't give
you their password do you think it's
cheating okay hide their phone from you
and doesn't give you their
password again she says not cheating he
says cheating the phone thing is weird
now I'm
old ever since I had a
smartphone I've been with Ela and ever
since I've known we've known each
other's passwords and stuff so it's it's
never we're not looking through each
other's phones at any point or anything
so I don't really know but if I was in a
relationship and I felt they were being
Cy about their
phone then that would make me
uncomfortable yeah
sureh cuz like I know as someone who's
in a monogamous relationship who's not
doing anything sussy that I you can look
through my phone any time a day anything
she's not going to find anything that
would make her
uncomfortable you know so the caginess I
agree it's a little sus is it cheating
who knows you know who knows who can
answer such
questions only
him if your partner follows another girl
on Instagram when they went out on a
night out and last one do you think it's
cheating notat okay I mean yeah that
one's not cheating I don't know that
that could be whatever if your partner
kissed someone on the lips but it was
just as a
friend what the okay F at least you
they got that one right they cropped it
though maybe she pointed both you know
in a weird way in a weird way I feel
like that one
is less cheating than some of the other
ones cuz like if they're close friends
oh yeah and they go like one of these
are we talking about like they're making
out cuz clearly they like I mean I don't
know some people do that are we also
talking about like if I kiss one of my
best friends like at a if me and my are
just chilling I think they said like the
the opposite sex or whatever
heterosexual
desires you know very interesting stuff
though here
guys I want to see your blind reaction
to whether you think something is okay
did we learn anything that was
interesting that was
fun we learned something I don't know
what but something was learned actually
so this Segways into another thing I
want to talk to you guys about I saw
this Tik Tok of somebody interviewing
Japanese
people about cheating culture it
blew my mind dude this is going
to blow your
minds wait is this the video is
considered no more things oh this and
hold
on where's the where's the Tik Tok I
sent I saw here's his channel oh yeah
this is him
send you guys
a uh I we'll check the chat I don't
remember that I I found this subject
somewhere else um I don't remember you
sending a yeah there's a he's
interviewing women specifically about
it uh here's the one where he's talking
to men and then there's another one
where he's talking to women it's in this
video if you can find the time stamp
okay but here he is talking a minut
about
it which was less shocking than than the
[Music]
women's do you think Japanese people
cheat I wouldn't say there are many but
I do have some friends who
do many for
friends yeah and I know some of them
cheat
too you wouldn't say that nationality
matters I feel Japanese men in
particular cheat more than other
men do prostitution counts as
cheating personally I don't think so
dude this whole world is about to blow
your
mind I don't think
so why
not is when one person wants to do the
ACT but the other person is just doing
their
job I think that cheting is when both
parties involved want to do the act so
so as long as the prostitute doesn't
want to you
that's very very weird to say okay
interesting Nuance oh and I'm
telling you man
it's yeah that's why I think the
prostitution is different from
cheating dud this guy's just drinking a
beer out in public too I love it Japan
is wild dude they're
wild I guess I've learned from this that
prostitution is like a really big
cultural kind of phenomenon
there do you think most Japanese men
don't consider prostitution
cheating I think
so then is it okay for women to go see a
male
prostitute even with the r reverse I
don't think that changes anything okay I
like the consistency at least
yeah bro I
would I am not ready for my wife to get
down by King Dong The
[Music]
Prostitute like what the you know
what I
mean you think your foreign friends
would be surprised to hear that that you
think prostitution isn't
cheating I never talked with them about
it but love hotels are apparently
illegal in places like Canada and UK
love hotels dude is it just a brothel is
that what that means but I love the
euphemism it's just a love Hotel it's
kind of crazy how it's so
Des
destigmatized that's why I think Japan
is a little different from other
cartoons in regard to
sex it's not really a brothel it's more
it's a hotel that's just primarily
operated for the purpose of allowing
guests privacy during sexual AR all
hotels private I was going to say in
America we just call that Motel 6 I
justed the door yeah right I
mean I don't expect there to be cameras
or anything you
know all right here's T talking to three
other dudes do you think Japanese people
cheat I do he says yes seems like it he
says what about your
friends many
do far as I've heard yes not really he
says y all are same friends right are
you
strangers all of my friends cheat uh I
don't know I never heard such a
thing he's telling the
truth is there any particular reason why
Japanese men often
cheat because they want to have
fun other count Japan has a culture of
hiding
things have you ever
cheated ni yeah right didn't he say it
he just said he did didn't he he says I
have not well he said it he says I have
not they all said I have not and they
all definitely have look at
him he said at the start of the intro
yeah I do oh he said yeah I do believe
yeah that okay well do you think now
here comes the question do you think
prostitution counsil is cheating believe
it I don't think
so
no and then this guy who's Chad Giga
Chad he says I think it does count as
cheating so one interesting now did you
find the time stamp of the women cuz
that's the one that blew my mind the
most yeah I think it's this Tik Tok set
okay dude watch this
ladies here so here's asking ladies now
does prostitution count cheating yes
them it does not it does not they both
said I would like it if they have
feelings for the I wouldn't like it if
they had feelings but I don't care if
it's just for
sex I'd rather to go to a prostitute and
talk to a random girl
whoa Jesus how that's so different
that's just so
different different perspectives I mean
Gary ve is losing his mind over
this uh this girl says it does it is
cheating I don't want I don't understand
if they want to go to a
prostitute she says it doesn't count she
say as long as they're not hiding it and
there's no feelings for the prostitute
honey well I'm going to go see uh I'm
going to go see
uh I'm going to go uh to the love Hotel
I'll be
back and
30 10 in my case now I got to say I'm
Googling around and like obviously these
this is a Tik Tok with some anecdotal
interviews um I did found uh the only
kind of stats I can find on this was
this worldwide survey about Affairs in
particular now I guess there's Nuance
here because maybe in Japan going to a
prostitute is not considered an affair
that's the difference specifically about
prostitution because on Affair is
considered to be a moral issue France
not not to be a moral issue France T 40%
of France says it's not a problem to
have an affair um Japan's all the way
down at 14% similar Italy wait hold on
hold on hold on France 40% they they
getting down in France man so they think
monogamy isn't important too seems very
odd I mean I don't believe that it's
different to
perspectives Spain 27 Germany 26 man
what I don't believe different
perspectives senagal Canada 17 I mean
there's a lot of Canadians here is that
true
17 that's a big I mean America isn't on
here but I would expect it to be in a
similar range nah dude we're so
puritanical I bet it's single dig single
dig bro I don't know about that do you
know one person that would answer answer
this
question well again I guess it just all
depends on how the question is posed
because we're we're seeing here that
Affairs consider not to be a moral issue
Japan's way far down but we don't have
the Nuance of knowing that they don't
consider going to a prostitute well no
this this is this is specifically
talking about a connection with another
person well let me see if I can find
some stats on America as a European I
don't think that's correct at all it's
surprising h no I don't I doubt that's
true Britain 15 Italy 16 Japan 17
Australia
13 well anyway the the prostitution
specifically is the one that blew my
mind uh here here's
more she says it does not also it does
not both of them said it doesn't as long
as they don't hide
it I told my boyfriend go to a
prostitute if you want to
cheat it's okay if he pays
money they just pay money instead of
meeting new
girls it does not if there's a decent
reason what the
that's the decent
reason Loveless
marriage companionship oh well then your
your relationship isn't working like
with their boss wait like they go
together wait like the boss and the
employee go
to like a com like one of those bars
yeah they like go together like hold on
hold on let me read this again let me
she says not if there's a good reason
okay what's and she and he says what is
the good reason
like what
companionship like with their boss and
she said
yes
huh as long as you're tapping sacks with
your boss while you do it for
real I guess you know work is very
important in that world you know you
don't want to if you have opportunity to
tap sacks with your boss do
it excuse nothings
together uh
soot wow and these are
these she said I would get
upset but it's still
acceptable kind of part of Japanese
culture she
said Japan is famous for its
prostitution so maybe it's only in
Japan I got to say just you know really
shocked the hell out of me I couldn't
even believe what I was watching okay so
I have to the only thing I could find
was this gallop
poll uh from a long time ago though so
is from 2001 so a lot can change
culturally in 20 years but in 2001
Gallup did a poll on Americans and uh
only 9% said that Affairs are not
morally wrong in America in in America %
so you said you said single digits
you're right 9% barely made it but again
2001's 22 years ago uh who knows maybe
it's different now do you know one
person in your whole life life that
would say having an affair doesn't count
no I guess not I mean I've known
probably I've known people through my
life that were pretty wild but if right
now no nobody that I'm CL with anyting
someone has an interesting Paradox here
what if Kink shaming is your
Kink what if King oh my God but they say
don't King Shame but you said well King
shaming is my king why are you king sham
right I get well hm what happens
now yeah I'm going to close this poll
there it is people
Japan there it
is Japan is all about the respect
apparently not Logan uh well I thought
you're a good
source uh here is a guy no I don't want
to talk about this guy he's
boring boring I want to talk about oh
this guy is fascinating we have the eel
pit too well we should talk about our
about Mr Beast winning the Super
Bowl bro congrats
Jimmy long time
coming is the largest stadium in the
world hold on Mr Beast joins the NFL
isn't funny enough we got to change it
to like Mr Beast getting dragged on
Twitter for being a loser Mr be ruins
something Mr Beast is dragged on Twitter
for being a dork Mr Beast dragged on
maybe just dragged on Twitter roasted
maybe
roasted you I like roasted roasted here
we have a donation
from women in South Korea are protesting
by withholding dating and sex to change
the misogyny there and it's impacting
birth rates it's crazy holy that's
interesting that's
solidarity okay Mr Beast dragged on
Twitter for being a you want more for
being pro is dor ass
loser for saying wait what did you talk
Isel you I was asking you you said for
being for being a dork loser or
something dork ass
loser it's not very nice to Mr Jimmy
Beast no it's not he get he get he gets
dragged on Twitter for wearing tights
all right so just dragged on
confusing yeah so anyway let's get into
that though so Mr Beast is appeared at
an NFL game in full Tampa Bay Bucks
uniform so I don't believe he's a
football fan I don't believe he has any
association with the box it seems like
the NFL probably paid him to be here
yeah well he he explains it a little bit
uh in number two but if you want to
start with this video so here NFL tagged
them they actually didn't get that many
views either for
them no I did pretty bad yeah he had a a
Super Bowl commercial last year wait for
what what was it uh do you guys remember
I don't wasn't he in one or maybe he did
yeah right of course he had a Super Bowl
commercial it was like a phone
commercial yeah here that's where here's
me and reacting to it there you go yo
why this broke idiot didn't even run a
beast
bar ad that was for like a cell phone
company or something doesn't yeah
doesn't he get like twice the viewership
of Super
Bowl actually well get a lot of views he
gets 200 million views a video so does
the Super Bowl exactly so he doesn't
need that he doesn't get 200 million
live what do you think the crossover is
like in the with the audience pools not
a lot they
com's see Super Bowl live viewership
yeah the NFL 100 this year's Super Bowl
had 113 million live viewers that's
crazy that's a lot of live viewers yeah
is that PT or at pre- Taylor or after
Taylor that pre that was PT dude we're
in the new era now New Era tour hey all
right so here's Jimmy uh tearing up the
field and
tights he got him in they got him in the
tights man they did it to him why' they
have to do it it's got no audio either
but what is there really no audio Yeah
they posted it without no audience so
weird he's signing the jerseys like he's
on the team I've never seen that man
look like he doesn't belong
somewhere he's always in charge Mr B
sign my Buccaneers
Jersey I forget that he's 6'5 the dude
is a he's not 65 he's 65 no he's not
I've met him so I've met him a bunch of
times he's like he's tall he's not 65
always heard he's really tall and I've
seen people on Twitter say 65 maybe they
were just meing he's maybe 63 63 gole
says because he's under 5T tall this is
this is Beast
propaganda 2 Ines my bad my bad 2 Ines
is everything bro it's a lot it's a very
very very long yeah that's
significant anyway there's the Beast
let's see how people he responded to it
I guess because he's getting a little
dragged they gave me a 28 hour contract
for video hopefully I get some time I
don't think he was admitting they paid
him I think he's saying they're going to
let me play for 48 hours like they
signed him as a player it's a joke right
he's joking do not play this man
um let's
see I just got measured at 65 why am I
still getting taller in my 20s
man H there's no way there's no way he's
6'5 H wait that's from yesterday yeah
it's from yesterday how's possible so
funny why did you send this from
yesterday did you read
this yeah did you read this AB before
you yeah how did you stumble upon this
huh I read it somewhere that's why I was
going back to look from yesterday it's
from yesterday bro weird how did he know
wait AB you have some explaining to do
what do you mean AB I feel like Mr Beast
has some exp to
you he's not
6'5 and I'll die on this
hill um well how old is he Mr Beast a
early 20s he 25 the guy grew two inches
n in his mid 20s unless he's got like
gigantism or whatever that Tony Robin
is is that what it's called what Tony
Robbins got that like oh no he had like
a tumor that that like changed his
biology or something that made him super
only Robins yeah he had like a t I know
that patory tumor in his brain patory
grind yeah it up his levels of human
growth hormone let's go I want to do
that yeah I know where's I I even
joking cancer but sorry you can get that
big on human growth
hormone I'm
growing he's a monster in
his right it's like his whole
stick just being big yeah and his a deep
voice and being big do you remember the
like first Bigfoot on on Stern like he
was like 7 fo6 his voice was so
deep I don't know the old one I just
know the current one this guy's voice
was like it sound like he had a
harmonizer on his voice and he was
massive it was nuts was it as deep as
Corpse husband deeper bro y so here's
here's the resp
so sorry guys I'm just going to show my
wrist
today
H guys
I everyone's been looking for that song
did we find the full song or is it not
out yet it's not it's not out that was a
little preview from what I recall a
little the world is waiting to his loyal
fans you're not there I there you're not
there beat him to Market yeah why not he
up he it's like leaking like
pre-production stuff we got to get on
that we should steal it and make a
song with those I don't see any
issues copyright it yeah copyright
it comfort him dude that' be sick
here's the responses to Beast uh here's
one he says bro thinks he's on the team
that was my thought Buck's already taken
an l and this isn't even the 1 p.m. yet
why y all lost this is why y all lost
weird Vibes not going to lie that's
embarrassing great the Mr Beast curse is
a thing now oh no so sports sports
audience are very superstitious I have
to say I think genuinely people are
going to blame him for the loss
well well they' be right because uh if
you look at number three on this list I
think it's number three uh this dude is
the team captain bro it's crazy
hold on let me open
it yo he's team cap lead the group cap
iine being an NFL player you trained
your whole life an elite athlete and
then you running out behind Mr
Beast oh we back it up we missed the
very start where he runs out some of
these guys are not having it let me go
back to the
beginning he's leaving the team this
dude thinks he's Tom Brady dudee and
Carl Jacob Carl Jacobs who isn't in a
uniform for some reason is
looking with peace and love he's kind of
looking like a make a wish kid if I'm
being honest but God bless him love him
it
[Music]
really get out there
guys this guy's walking he's like nah
not doing
[Music]
it this is the largest stadium in the
world
this is the largest stadium in the world
oh wow
perfect oh yeah baby all right where's
the Beast flag get rid of that
you remember that
movie why is he at the head it's so
funny he's like so accepting of the
praise too bro he's he's
Rudy man that's what say dud out here
like he's Rudy he's Rudy man
this dude thinks he's got like five
World
ring about to really protect me when I'm
on that field he's special teams for
sure let's go bucks he's he's the kicker
bro that's some Johnny Football
right there man I think people okay Mr
Beast is a cultural phenomenon who is
enormously famous however I do think
it's possible that people are starting
to
misunderstand or overestimate his
popularity mhm I feel like this is
Jumping the Shark this is in Jump shark
moment definition of it like I'm not
going to I'm not going to fault him if
the bucks or the NFL is like yo I'll
give you a million dollars to pretend
you're Rudy for an afternoon
yeah you know like I'm not going to
blame him for
that at look at this headline barcal
Sports Mr Beast is squarely to blame for
the Buccaneers
loss that phone is awesome sely that's
funny that
one leave him alone guys his dreams are
coming true right now let let him have
the day oh no I have always said Mr
Beast is like the closest thing to God
we have on this Earth I agree he has
well if that's true they would won
magical
pull and it's a little it's a little H
go well it's like I told you when I was
playing uh I was playing poker with him
at the casino people just were coming
and giving him money what the wow
like the richest dude in the room
probably people were just like different
people at different times were coming up
and get handing him money and saying him
cash just handing him cash I've never
seen anything like it my whole life he's
the he's like here take $100 please a
different person came up said here take
my chips
please why three different people it's
the god pull I'm telling you something's
up he's something's happening he's just
God and he accepted it too that's kind
of thanks man like he accepted as rich
as he is without uh doing that it
he accepted it okay he needs some money
dude okay he had a
his security guard was there with a
backpack full of leftover money from a
video they did full of like $5 bills or
something he had like $100,000 of $5
bills in his
backpack at the casino at the poker
table so weird seems dangerous well he
he had a security guard I mean I don't
think people knew what was in there
they're being sussy about
it but you can't with sports
fanatics you know what I mean you can't
mess with
is uh is his ongoing uh um like human
experiment on those two people that he
locked up you think that's still going
on like he still still got two people
just likeed up in a room while he's
doing this yes something a little weird
about that isn't there that's the
beginning of a Twilight Zone episode
where they come out and everyone's dead
and gone right did the last two people
on they were participating in Mr Beast
challenge well here's L Wayne leading
the charge of the
Packers dude that is amazing he looks
like a baby that's F he's so small oh my
God no way he's so small oh wait how
tall is Lil
Weezy little
Yeezy yeah
Weezy like open mouth run he's
55 with an attitude he's fine say that
with a little attitude a you tell 5 fo
three you tell Lil Wayne 2 Ines doesn't
matter
yeah um it seems like he's more in the
moment you know what I mean I think he's
an actual Packers fan too he's got the
is that a Packers uh neace Green Bay
necklace so he's out there repping the
fam I think that's the other thing yeah
is that Mr be from not Tampa Bay
Florida just seems odd that he's doing
it for that team specifically this is
actually kind of nice you can see how
soaked he is adorable yeah I love him
okay he's not a child Olivia even though
he's no I love him yeah he's so cute he
is he's so
tiny he does have a child like Wonder In
that clip you have to you have to admit
it oh he looks gaping mouth so they
showed this a cool moment for sure has
been linked to the Packers for a long
time of course I selfishly dreamt how
fun it would be for me to be with the
Buccaneers but surely
but it surely wouldn't happen nothing
more than a pipe dream but then today I
saw the Buccaneers do it with Jack ma
wannabe uhoh Mr be oh they're going in
for the record this is not a shot at
Jack Mack why is he calling him
that Insider uh Jack Mack is a uh
another bar stool employee I'm seeing uh
he does look like Mr Beast actually
interesting uh I definitely see some I
know this guy I know who this guy is
yeah um he's clearly more handsome than
Mr Beast Mr Beast looks like a poor
man's Jack Mack but unlike Jack Mack
this guy didn't get people fired up the
team came out flat going for it in the
fourth and sixth in Atlanta territory
and turning the ball over on Downs he's
not wrong he I think he might have
up the energy cuz you saw when
Lil Weezy came out it was all excitement
but Beast came out and he cooled
everything off I think because Little
Wayne didn't come out in a outfit I feel
like part tights yeah it's the wearing
the uniform I think that kind costume
makes it weird you're right if Lil Wayne
was wearing like the full outfit like
I'm playing tonight coach put me in bro
thinks he's Brady bro you know if he wor
an outfit that would look like a make a
wish yeah Mr Beast was LARPing yesterday
yeah yeah he continues let me be clear
this loss is not on the Bucks Mr Beast
is a huge draw and has millions of on
millions of followers he was a great
choice on the surface but the guy
doesn't have the passion for the team
like a real di hard fan would I mean
look at this and here is another one
that same oh wait no this this is that I
think they meant to show the Wheezy
one no they're saying he doesn't he he
doesn't look hype enough like you're not
that guy pal yeah yeah he's not hype
enough he says I would have run out like
my hair was on fire the crowd would have
no choice but to give a standing over
the team would have been fired up scored
first and set the tone on defense
guaranteed win there's no such thing but
as close as you can come with me leading
the team out of the tunnel Mr Beast I'm
glad you like the bucks but let's not
make this a reoccurring thing wow do you
guys think uh Mr V was there just
filming a video curing a thousand
football players of
CTE that would actually be really nice
to do it's more than the NFL's doing
I've hired I've fired 1,000 or all just
to come out here and diagnose each NFL
player we're giving them proper
treatment going to spend the next 50
hours buried
alive uh here's he let's
see yeah it's pretty funny actually I
got to say pretty funny no hate to the
Beast though on this this is all in the
buck for allowing this to happen
and take that from me someone who's
literally watched like two football
games in my life so an expert yes
and other words there he
is Die Hard Bo fan why are all the
pictures of Carl like that you leave him
alone it just looks so funny Oh my he
looks tiny it's like a perspective thing
but look he looks like he looks like
he's like six why does he look so
little
the water
boy right yeah oh my God that's so
funny there it is a is cuz it's his eth
birthday run out on the field bro thinks
he's Rudy all right I got to pee and
then we'll get to the Aiden Ross thing
which is pretty funny too and then I
have oh I got to do the chiro champ I
know I've seen a lots of people saying
no more chiropractor videos so I just
get I'll warn you with peace and love
before I do it but this one is really
funny warn you the answer is no we will
never stop the
like I understand if some people have a
hard time watching it but the last
chiropractor segment we did I saw so
many people being like that was the
funniest segment ever yeah it's so funny
the you're talking about the old woman
face I mean that that's like the best
meme that's come out of the show in a
long time I love that thing yeah and I
mean
like you know you're going to tell me
this shouldn't have
happened come on oh I love her we have a
name for her yet Babs Babs no pain L
they call her no pain line oh no pain
line I like Babs you know pain here she
is having it's almost passing
out from pain she looks like she's
telling us her name bab yeah it's me
bab it's your girl bab is my eyes
looking better uh no no no no okay it
does it does look worse on camera um you
think so I think it's BR out the red in
your skin tone um more than to the eye
definitely I'm going take photos so you
guys can see the closeups you on my
insta stories oh yeah that looks that
looks
crazy just no context
here uh if you're following my
[Music]
[Applause]
insta yeah I don't know it does look
pretty crazy on camera it's on my insta
stor up if you want to see thank you all
right at least it's not about Israel and
Gaza
true so thankful for that all right I'm
going to go to the bathroom and then
I'll be back
okay uh somebody just donated a few
minutes ago 60 gifted memberships
Chrissy Sherlock so thank you
Chrissy Chrissy wake up Chrissy wake up
let's order some
boba boba are you are you playing with
me right now love that does sound kind
of
good wait dan are you playing with me
right now I haven't had a boba in a
minute we haven't ordered since I
arrived I've been very patient wait what
no yep I know that every time in Sweden
at 2:00 I was like you guys are
ordering Boba I I can't wait till I get
there so I can eat Boba drink Boba too
and then you guys stop cuz it's
unhealthy right I will never St drinking
B the year I don't know what this guy is
about the Boba hate yeah let's get it
going get going yeah it's good to
be back Boba it's good to be
back here good to have you back zachie
welcome back zachie the show feels
awkward without you what did you did you
see did somebody say glad you're back or
something no I just want to say it's
good to be back hell yeah bro kind of
declared it yeah it's be back okay it's
good to have you back for sure Zach
you're not leaving soon are you cuz
don't you have another show
soon wow well thank you for the plug yes
uh if I may uh this Sunday I'm doing a
surprise Halloween show what wait it's
not a surprise it's not it's a surprise
surprise what makes it a surprise if
you're telling us about cuz I'm saying
it's a surprise that is not on Halloween
it's uh Sunday October 29th at this
place called the last call now that's
surprising tickets are only available at
the door limited
capacity oh what yeah isn't this the
last show in America yes wow the last
show in America yes last show you going
overseas where you
going I'm learning a lot right now yeah
last show in America that's a day before
my
birthday what yep important so where is
where is this uh where is the venue it's
called The Last Call it's in Tarzana
California right okay
Tarzana it's a Halloween spectacular so
um is it going to be a spooky good time
it's going to be a I feel like
tickets just at the door you're going to
have so many more people that can get in
show up now it's limited capacity it's I
wanted to do something kind of a little
smaller okay um so I think grand old
good fun time Co what's the capacity
just so people can get a sense of like
How likely they are to it's about 200
people oh okay that's a decent amount
yeah it's a decent amount and you'll be
in costume yes but I'm not going to say
what I'm oh I have a guess are you going
to play the Monster Mash I will play the
Monster Mash yeah we're going to we got
some spooky uh Halloween Tunes wow I
guess you don't want to give away all
the surprises no we got we got some fun
stuff though okay are you going to play
a
thriller maybe you going to play Time
Warp that was actually a possibility of
course well I have rehearsal later so I
appreciate all the uh the tips and if
you have any song requests you know
anything from Rocky Horror oh hell yeah
I wanted to dress up like uh um Franken
F oh that'd be so sick I did when we did
uh Rocky Horror at school I did makeup
for Franken ferter I played guitar in
the uh house Band Yo for the uh that in
um uh Cabaret very cool yeah great show
fun stuff how was your guys it's good to
have you back oh yeah thank you thank
you I appreciate appreciate that our
weekend was fun me and Cameron and Lena
went to twitchcon oh yeah a lot of fun
and last night we went to uh an IT
themed escape room like the film it in
Vegas and that was really fun if you
live in Vegas you check it out it's
really cool was it
scary scared for Lena it was there was
one point wherea scares from anything
though there was one point where the
clown jumped out and Lena like the way
she flew back like she got shot point
blank with a shotgun she screamed yeah
ah when I when I did that uh for a
couple years at a theme park people like
Lena are they're the best they make the
job so much fun it amazes me how fast
they could single her out like they know
right away like this is the one to go to
100% like after cuz I did it I did you
know it runs for like the whole month of
October or whatever um and by like the
second weekend that I was doing it you
get an instinct about who is just going
to fold when you scare like you can just
start to like sniff them out instantly
and oh man that was that was good times
good times doing that like a fun job to
have when you're like in college what is
the policy about like if you
accidentally like touch a person I mean
if it's an accident obviously you just
apologize and hope that they don't
report you because you're absolutely not
allowed to touch people and if you do
and they get upset and Report you you
probably get fired I a couple people did
get fired over the course of me doing it
um from what may or may not have been
accidental contact that happened or
whatever I certainly bumped into people
a few times but obviously you know
that's not a big deal right right right
yeah damn and he's
back Co priz it's good to have you back
you think you w b people saying new Dan
lore alert I've totally talked about
this on the show before I knew that yeah
I knew that too yeah but maybe they're
newer fan maybe they hadn't heard that
that lore yeah I did it for 2 years at
uh at Six Flags Magic Mountain here in
LA and uh I was I was one of the
monsters with prosthetic makeup on and
everything that's like a California
Pizza Kitchen I was going to say did you
work in at CPK with the full makeup on
yeah I think that's actually where I did
it yeah it was the
haunt and did you slide on your knees
and stuff I did I slid on my knees and
stuff with uh with a pizza cutter and I
just slice people's the kiles tendons it
was sick or you would cut pies with a
chainsaw
did you like some
Parmesan um Zach somebody asked if
you're going to uh make it one day over
to Scotland Scotland yeah for a show
would you would you travel maybe out to
the Moors out to the foggy
Moors the Moors yeah that what it's
called it's the terrain the moops the
what the moops I think a Sefi jump oh
got it hit got it got it got it got it
got it got it got it the moves the
Bubble Boy episode oh didn't hit didn't
hit I got there we're moving damn that's
some that's a deep cut Cameron yeah
sorry you're not eating for next we yeah
what else is though Ethan I have several
super chats with uh advice for your eyes
go ahead Ethan I've had eczema my whole
life and I highly recommend trying ukine
eczema relief cream those eggshells it's
not eczema dude I've seen the dermat
nothing works better I swear no uh they
those eggshells all right you know what
it I'll put it on yeah try it I'll
put it all on and there was another one
e what's it called uh that one was
called Uh u UK yukarin UK spell it ukine
e u c e r i
n uin c r i m USM eczema cream that's
the onea relief cream I'm loading up oh
wait but before you buy that hold on
hold on hold on I know I have this
oh or well I have this those eggs oh
that's what I'm putting on my
eyes oh you're using that yeah Alie had
it and she she gave it to me for my eye
all right so I'll get 10 of these what
else all right 10 of those and then
Ethan talk to your doctor about skin
mites or demo decks they cause rashes
around the eyes and nose and is fairly
easy to solve Dan please tell him and
say hi to Alison for me your girl is
awesome okay I will thank you thank you
Meg demon dogs and Demon skines oh you
got mites
dude skin bugs bro you got skin bugs how
does that happen that's nasty Prett sure
I like you got bugs in your skin
dude lean and the bug
skin exoskeleton
bro uh anything else anyone else any
other diagnosis
uh any more let's see let's see any
other diagnos
diagma anybody saying anything more
about Lima balls
bro anybody suggested that you go to a
chiropractor for your eye true oh you
know what we have actually a uh your
your aunt is coming right to do the yeah
chiropractor not chiropractor she does
acupuncture she's going to acupuncture
me yes we're going to do live
acupuncture which is a lot less
the consequence of doing that which I
believe is a pseudo
science is zero unless they are not
cleaning their needles or something
psycho where that would be very very bad
if they wer cleaning their needles
that's super important so it's more
harmless than chiropra
zero all right zero zero
you let's talk about Aiden Ross this man
so twitchcon
happened what what maybe you were there
what happens at twitchcon what is what's
what is it yes uh it's just sort of a
cool place in network and meet with your
audience uh me and Cameron and Lena went
and it was cool yeah they have like some
like booths for like Elgato and
different equipment you could try out
and uh yeah I heard I heard you saw the
uh gamer Subs guy there that they were
super nice yeah they're really nice guys
they came up to us and uh said hello and
they recognized us and uh yeah they said
they appreciate us and they're really
kind they offered us to sit at their if
we ever wanted to hang out or needed a
break from the floor I said Thank you
sick I love gamer Subs
Man Zero
lead as far as I can
tell why would it doesn't have it's
purified to the
maximum cheers my
dudes we saw Pok there as well no lead I
say it with my chest what I was saying
we ran into Poky main there as well oh
that's nice said hi to me
Alena very
good very very good
mhm so wait fans go there just to like
meet their favorite creators uh
sometimes yeah and do you pay to go
there yeah you have to pay mhm is there
a creater pass or general pass uh yeah
but everyone kind of mixes on the uh the
same floor but you could get like a a
meet and greet I don't know what the
threshold is I got an email about it but
I didn't respond to time we saw the
twitch C just walking around
with uswhere many times throughout the
convention that goofy ass that goofy ass
wizard looking
weirdo I hope someday he makes me a
partner on Twitch right careful shout
out careful cam so Aidan Ross got kicked
out I guess he's banned he got banned on
Twitch yes and I guess if you're banned
on Twitch you're also banned at
twitchcon and this dude showed up ah
he's such a goon man he shows up with
the whole posy of people wearing
kick
shirts how are you real
dude here it is crazy that's crazy I
don't even do it damn we was in here
like what 3 minutes bro we W good Loop
what the did I do
W oh wow bro Eddie this is bad it's
still W kick a good look let me how many
people is he with there like 30 people
it seems like they're all walking with
him and wearing kick
shirts yeah they all came together bro
you don't need that big of a posy I know
you don't you do not need an Entourage
bro you need like one person to help you
film and maybe a security guard cuz
you're
live crazy that's crazy I don't even do
it damn we was in here like what what
the he's got like a
army 3 minutes bro
we what the did I do you're going
to let this old man kick all you guys
out
what what
uh kind of good point yeah what what's
he going to do mhm kick they were trying
to push back at first but then
ultimately he's like the police are
right outside and they're like all right
let's talk to them
nice wow bro Eddie this is bad man it's
still W kick is a good look let me
switch self as also he's live
streaming I don't I heard you're not
supposed to live stream in there right
no you can oh you can you just can't in
the uh members Lounge I see yeah
I I knew she had F
crazy okay so there that is uh
condolences it's just not fair our boy
Aiden he demands
respect do you know who he is do you
know how many people are in his
Entourage yes
so the next one is actually even better
he posted this or maybe it's one of his
clip channels or whatever but this
actually shows the how long it was
before they got approached by
security okay so here is nice 8 minutes
this first part is called sneaking in
which doesn't say a lot about his
intentions going here right or does say
a lot about his intentions going
through oh we're in yeah we're in
twitchcon chat so that they just walked
onto the floor that's that's the
entrance it's at the Vegas Convention
Center good thing he's keeping a low
profile right and there's like a lobby
area and pretty much immediately you can
walk through that Archway that he just
walked through to to get to the show for
got it so see how long it takes for him
to get kicked out all right let's see
where I want to meet the CEO you know
what I'm saying Eddie told me to be
really nice I want to I want to actually
ask him a couple questions all chat
where do I find the CEO at bro where do
I fight him at bro I can't get kicked
out I'm showing up a la I love everyone
here you get what I'm saying I love
everyone here but I got to find the see
y want to talk to him real quick chat um
chat
why my feet burning I'm not here to ca
problems all right I'm here toe I love
in the back of the back you know we love
twitch over here too I want to get
unbanned all right CH I'm going to ask
him to unban me uh so where is he at
chat tell me where to go and I'll find
him oh my God I have anxiety bro swear
to God
[Music]
I mean he's lasting a while I'm yeah you
know I think it just cut forward like a
minute or two right here though okay
okay he's having a time of his life man
he's out
there we're s nobody's noticing him e
not yet expect he that he some like
people would come say hi or some
you know like
who's go ahead let me kit just lead
bro can't stay still bro there's like
100 of them surrounding me bro like
tails and chat chat do want to be
all
we better not bro you're not
animals you're all humans all
[Music]
right for
what oh that's
awesome so you didn't really even get to
go anywhere you didn't like nothing
pretty much immediately got spotted and
they're not walking through the circle
they're going like around everything
right they went straight and then this
is like the back area keeping it low
profile
[Music]
yeah what do we do what do we do back
your ass up bro what do I here for 5
seconds but I
paid trying to I paid they trying to
kick us out what do I have to leave for
for the kick shirt of death I
paid me and my whole posy paid bro
there's like 30 of us you know how much
money that cost
me
buddy actually that is a how much is the
ticket AB uh it's different for partners
I think let me double Che he's not a
partner though right he's not even right
for non Partners it was like $220 for
the whole
weekend so he probably did waste a
significant amount of money on this dumb
thing because I mean there's got to be
at least 10 people here with him right
well and as you're going to see in the
next clip he wasted a lot more of other
people's money as well oh fantastic sck
[Music]
yion this now this links up with the
video we watched earlier now it's just
it's him getting escorted out yeah this
is
bad sking for supposed to be moving like
here we go 20 minutes is
[Music]
crazy damn nobody cares about him
actually I how we going oh there's one
okay yeah like the first person can you
tell me what I did just don't touch
me hey hey look how Cy little baby he is
I love these stupid security
guards they have no idea what they're
they have no idea of what's going on I
feel so bad oh man I the guy when you
say that I immediately think about
fousey's guard that was there during the
whole
police that poor guy man and he was
sitting there silent just listening oh
my that that was a night he won't forget
that was something that was something
all right uh dude look how scared you
are of this like freelance
security guard Aiden you don't touch
me my guard is armed bro don't touch me
right now all right have a good one okay
please what did I do can you tell me
what I did just don't touch me
real not trying to touch you it was
assault assault to me no hey hey let's
go we don't need to do
we're going to leave we're going leave
cuz they got cops over bro I'm not going
to let you get we talk to them bro got
can you tell me what I did that's why I
want to know what I
did we're going to
[Music]
leave wow this was really cool what they
did this worked out they really showed
twitch that was awesome man they showed
them fat dub huge dub Wade and
was what I do that's want to
know I didn't even know who
he these people have violated violating
twitch conduct what is it though I'm
curious what's the code of conduct have
to look they don't want you there bro
yeah he's some security guard like he's
not going to like start quoting Goos
violations get the out yeah they
don't want you
there that's
it I'm just curious what I did though I
that's all want to know what I did you
there's there's a bunch of to well
you which is what though all right Aiden
you were one of the biggest streamers in
the world and clearly you didn't know
to so why don't you leave old
man alone the security guard so maybe
he's but maybe he's telling the truth
then he's like dude I don't I still
don't know what happened do you know
yeah maybe I don't know why I was banned
do you know why Mr security guard he
just wants a
friend I don't know y don't even know
what yall King us out for bro you
guys know no we didn't sign
anything there's an agreement this guy's
kind of badass how he's holding his
ground against all these dudes he doing
great shout
out money bro I paid $300 well can we
get a sir can we get a refund is that
possible hell no no refunds time time's
rough you have to leave we don't what
I'm listen to the cop I'm not going to
listen to them listen to the cop cop do
I need need to leave yes oh okay
whatever you say sir I'm going listen to
you we get my money back what you asking
the cop the cop dumb ass imagine the cop
going up to catch ma'am you must refund
this
man the state demands it I hope they
like email twitch and ask for their
money back and they email him back with
a l sent him an
L charge it back Aiden loser you're used
to scamming and lying and doing all that
so go just charge it
back that's I don't know I was here for
5 minutes max and I they don't even tell
me what I did wrong they're just saying
you got to leave right no and I get it
but I'm this is this is their event dude
you're such a d if they want to take
pass you are such a dork loser this is
so not cool you look like such a fat
dork ass loser right
now
YT pass all right bro let's just F
they're just doing their jobs Bro
it it's cool bro they they just look
weak what was he going to do throw down
against the
car it's cool this we it's
cool bro they got to take off
thees and
shame the security guard should have
ripped them off them like you
know like a pendant being ripped from a
traitor
[Music]
there cops bro there
cops I I give my land I give it to him
he's not even with me
though just KZ wearing a kick shirt
doesn't mean a there's another kid wear
a kiir is not with us just because we
he's not with me just cuz we were
wearing matching uh shirts and came in
together and we're standing next to each
other at twitchcon he's not with me he
paid for this on his own C on his
own we going to leave bro we to leave
bro watch out what was the reason I
violated
to I didn't do anything wrong I didn't
do anything illegal how you going to
legally take he's not even with me sir I
would tell you he's not even with me
watch
out don't all right cool let him go have
fun by
himself you guys leave and you're one
Frank and go have all the fun he wants
at twitch G by himself going to and his
kick
sh what am I doing IL legally having my
bad legally it's a private oh and I'm
trying to leave and it's my purch all
right guys it's time to get out the
pepper
spray it's time to start tasing people
come on officer the one time I want to
see police OB right exactly where's the
brutality come on where's the bear mace
to his eyeball from 1 millimeter
away understanding is that you don't
purchase the badge you pay with the
registration property of it's property
of my property this is myice I
understand that but what I'm saying is
you if I don't you can trespass me go
ahead just leave oh my God what do you
think you're
doing this is just Caren Behavior at
this point being car it is it is it's
annoying because a lot of these people
here at twitchcon besides these
obviously are really kind people really
they look forward to that a lot it's
their escape I gotta deal with these
idiots can i t to make a comment
and maybe I'm off the back of Aiden's
head makes him look very
dumb I there's something about the way
the back of his head is sloped uhhuh the
slope not sloped that sounds
weird I'm not doing like skull
measurements now no no no I'm just I'm
saying how it like it some people the
back of their head it looks like it's
just like one shape like a
thumb flat and and oval shaped that
happens sometimes um when I think it's
when like babies aren't laid down
correctly I'm not saying this I think he
looks the back of his head looks very
intelligent to me I'm with Ethan looks a
little
flat I think the back of his head
probably did badly on its APS you think
it's a baby thing his no I don't know I
don't know if that's with him but I it's
potentially I think you grow out of that
no you don't if you let let a baby lay
down for too long they get Flathead I'm
pretty sure I know you're supposed to
you're supposed to switch their sides
time wait so I've always thought it
stayed do Google it look up a flat Dome
from B like I'm curious what happens cuz
if the man has like a
defect or maybe a feature I've seen some
people call it a fe I what would you
call it
Dan i' call it a perfectly normal head I
think his head is normal for the very
noral normal head I've seen today that
cannot be
true
who are you to say that baby
want never seen a more normal
head let me draw a picture so you guys
know what I'm talking
about hold on just move on from the from
the head measuring find me a picture of
the yeah I got it so you ever seen
someone with their back of the head look
oh how do I make this
thicker the new paint is kind of f like
they added all kinds of new features
clean so better right yeah it's really
nice phenology with Ethan Klein no this
isn't phenology not measuring his
Dome I do not believe in
phenology I just think his head he just
got a dumb head his the back of his head
looks like
[Music]
this you know what I mean it is
rectangular is rectangular dude there's
my job security right
there in my
this is like a Homer Simpson head are
those his hair strands you know it it
his fr the front looks normal but then
it just
like now what's that
right
right interesting this is okay it is
very hard to do this with a
finger yeah I don't know you know it's
obviously not a scientific an analysis
let's see what you're trying to say know
next time we talk about the conflict
overseas let's use that maybe it'll help
nope see I don't think this guy
has no no can I see it from the
back I let me see someone should tell
Aiden that he needs more Tummy Time
who's this guy I think it specifically
happens when they cut their hair really
short too so it's just like a bunch of
skin
and his hair is quite short in the back
okay whatever Noh that's what they
fighting over a
come bought why
bought I get your PO on it I
do get your PO on it but he's not with
me why do
you all right so this just this more of
this they look crazy yeah you get you
got the idea yep literally cuz we had
kick on it's
not no it's cuz you're a known
Menace it's probably a picture of you in
the security
office you
know uh let's see his friends who went
with him also got banned oh they tried
to escape later some of his friends
tried to Splinter
off yeah we got twitch hello s just
twitch is committed to keeping our
community safe and everyone as a part of
that we require all
Insurance wow you got defitely suspended
oh my oh my God I got to check my S just
got indefinitely suspended from twitch
chat wait wait wait wait wait what what
happened all the people that he was
with they several of them were streaming
their you know on Twitch doing oh you
can't stream with a banned person uh
probably that and also just the fact
that they participated in the stunt with
him uh but that's awesome they were on
this bus as they were leaving and one by
one all of their accounts started
getting banned so in like in real time
AR what an Entourage to be part of it
just became the Bang Bus hey bro you got
you got the K sh on
got Jesus Christ I got to check Mar wow
oh I'm good but I don't care what did
you do that's up you can't just
ban somebody forever for that that's
actually
F oh my God they banned this no that was
a huge dub man they really showed they
stuck at the
twit Karen by the way is uh what his
shirt actually was trying to say you
just didn't know how to read it
thanks uh with all that being said oh he
was banned for unmoderated hateful
conduct in his chat I guess streamers
have an obligation to make sure their
chat is properly moderated it doesn't
have racism and hate and stuff right and
he knew that for his twitch chat but
this is when kick first came out and he
was I guess Simo casting on Kick and
twitch and put his kick chat on scam so
it was showing his kick chat on his
twitch stream and it was just full of
lots of like you know what you would
expect kick chat was up for 20 minutes
without any moderation oh God it
included offensive comments including
racism anti-
semitism uh he's been banned seven times
for very I lengths yeah so he had
previously been banned seven times and I
guess this was the last draw they were
just like bye-bye all right finally I
want to talk about the chiro oh
it's kind of well I'll talk about the
chiropractor I've been putting this off
for too damn long so with peace and love
if you are not ready for chiropractor
videos although I think these are so fun
and they're so
funny I call them the Vampire Hunter
because he's literally driving stakes in
the people hell
yeah uh but yeah this I'm going to end
it after this so if if this
is not something you want to watch then
with peace and love this is a serious
message people have been posting this so
much on the subreddit I saw it a while
ago but this guy's a maniac um do we
have his Tik Tok
account I need his Tik Tok account you
see it uh I think this next link oh
ASMR all right so here it is this guy's
treating uh
scoliosis
[Music]
so bro is this Guantanamo Bay or a
doctor's
office bro
let me get a close look at that chisel
he's using
[Music]
too why so many times there's just he
puts like a napkin between
him just no way it's like going to make
me start crying like I feel so horrible
he paid him for this
man that that is a truly blood
curling
painful he's suffering that is wow that
is that that could be worth pulling I'm
definitely going to pull
it oh my God damn poor son of a
man there's a whole bunch of him going
to work with the Mallet and the St holy
here's this lady God bless
her uh this is so Psy this might be a
different guy this is the practice of
yeah I I did link you the uh your
favorite guy in the chat though thank
you yeah here's the Vampire
[Laughter]
Hunter oh God here we
go oh my God she's like please stop
no you got to be joking I'm sorry no
with The Gap I think this guy's
do that was just a stitch or whatever
yeah if you uh grab this link in the
Discord got lots more here's something
dude you guys want to know how far this
chiropractor shit's going I've shown you
dogs I've shown you kids MH but I have
yet to show
you a snake
chiropractor and again this man is
serious he is both a an expert in the
human he's dedicated his life to
understanding the human biology and he
also knows how to break snakes cracks
snake backs
too I mean arguably if anybody needs
chiropractor it's a
snake they're like 100% spine they're
all back yeah it's all back long
back this is so stupid you can't be
serious oh yeah that one really needs it
nice it's like T
80,000 how did they know the snake
needed this right bro these
have been been around for
billions of years yeah they don't need a
shut prer bro that's a great
Point like you idiot their
biology is perfected at this point yeah
who who told them to do this yeah you
know what I mean snake called them
up he said man I'm in pain look at this
idiot look at this
insane oh get a good angle there they
just have a weird fetish for cracking
bones like they don't care where they
they're kids they're dogs their snakes
they just need the crack they need the
crack it's all that matters they live
for it they dream of it they're
crackheads yeah these crack addicts too
crackheads for sure but here's my nobody
here would know what that's like though
well I did smoke it once
but not enough to say I understand what
it's like to be a
crackhead um let's take a look at this
[Laughter]
guy
[Music]
it's right over his
too oh my God he just died look at this
there's no way it's just
randomly there's no way a little down
here a little down there there is no
medical accuracy this man is just doing
random
shots look at this oh my god dude I say
he's carving
ice bro he's doing his legs now dude
what are know about
legs it in one minute it only takes a
minute in one
minute so this is good I mean this is
heroactors are real serious guys here's
a
lady oh this is a separate uh yeah this
is normal this guy's awesome I've seen
this guy he's really cool he really
helped him oh he really helped
him he's just punching him not even
using a tool he's just jackhammering his
back with his
hand you cannot be an empath and be a
chiropractor dude look at his
face oh now he brought
up so hard to watch you know like people
scoliosis depending on how bad it is
it's hard to even walk how bad
it oh yeah this guy has a really bad you
can tell when he's standing up it's a
severe case of degenera of scoliosis we
put him out of his
misery ow we killed him he's got
MMA gloves on too oh you can see how
yeah dude why are you torturing
him just do it like do like we do in
America just get give him some oxycotton
and
call Hooked on
[Applause]
that he's petting him I I mean obviously
I empathize with him but this just
cracks me
up it's so insane
I I cannot believe it's real a
[Music]
nightm leave him
alone
thank you look how Yeah well yeah he get
shot have scoliosis before he doesn't
know look at the shot of his face at the
end yeah Super Saiyan scor he's cured
guys look at his cured face he looks
great I
love so this is the Vampire Hunter
technique of chiropractor it's actually
from the Middle Ages invented by vampire
hunters
and later used on
come
on man there's one where it looks like
he's driving it up his ass trying to
find that one the one earlier
that's he's like look you're fine see
how you
move I cared
you his his body is telling him to
run so true I'm trying to find the one
where he drives it up his
ass yeah uh there was are you talking
about the one where they do the the
tailbone cracking that there was one
that you had shared that I I made the
call to actually take out because it was
like so graphic I think it's fine
they're doctors doing doctor stuff he
had his thumbs yeah he entirely up his
sphin he's a chiropractor you don't see
it it's over his clothing but medical
procedure bro I don't know man pull it
up amazing neurom monocular scoliosis
treatment amazing all right I'll try and
find
it Jesus amazing the
[Music]
breathing the sound of he
it's all good things guys it's get over
here here's a good one wow this is some
some of the more uh acceptable Western
uh Psychiatry or Psychiatry chiropracty
that you'll find you know in any big
city in America this is what's happening
with the spine young person 16 rotation
wow so this is bringing the ribs back
making forward so spine is going like
this let me show you he's literally
making up so now you can kind of
notice it do you notice it I never
noticed that you notice it now
[Music]
yeah what is he doing on the lever every
time he pushes the thing uh pops
down he's like gamifying it this is for
this is a medieval torture device
I was trying to look for the head poles
where is
that this is the I with wow
wow wow wow wow wow god wow all right I
I shared it AB is chiming in in our chat
he said he thinks it's too much too I me
let me watch it again pull it up there
was a few one was more graphic than that
this pretty crazy dude hold on let me
take it off
screen I mean he's a doctor he's got
gloves
on really you guys think this is too
much by the end of it hand is straight
up it's up there
bro it's over his clothing yeah yeah it
is you can't see anything okay are you
questioning the medical value of
this it's just a tailbone adjustment D I
will save my commentary until you make
the call on if you're showing it or not
I mean it's it's up to you it might be
okay you're feeling it I just I just
want give some some context or uh input
here uh it's educational we've witnessed
a man n his on YouTube right
that's true I'm not trying to get
demonetized though although I wonder if
his how does this video get so many
views if it's
demonetized because he's wiing his yeah
it went viral like everywhere I think
people people s it out you're going to
look so hot I doubt YouTube was
suggesting it although that would be
crazy that's death shocking severe
scoliosis bro bro are you cutting like
slabs of stone or are you traing
someone's back that's right he's a
sculptor sculpting these spines he
straight came straight from the stone
quarry it's not marble
[Music]
man say for us she's actively
crying dude this not okay he's
getting annoyed with her I think he's
like CH enough with he's like looking up
talking to
someone pipe down or I'll do some
Buckshot hits so funny I just rained
hell on your back from random spots so
this guy this doctor puts two thumbs up
his butthole over his clothes he has a
thin orange pants on and he goes in from
outside is that cheating a nice Lin no
no the question is does he smell his
thumbs
afterwards
MH what if he smells what if what what
if he smells is it cheating
then I think it's okay to show all right
I mean you're you're you're the expert
you guys all really think I shouldn't
show it anyway I'll act it out I just I
watched it this morning I was going over
the dock and it shocked me so much that
I was like I don't think we can show
this on the show that was my instinct
but if you think it's all right you go
for it looks like a doctor he's wearing
gloves the guy's on his back with his
feet up he puts both of his thumbs in
his pretty deep I mean pretty
deep you know full thumb and then he
pushes
down crack the tailbone really inventive
yeah I think it's a woman too yeah I
think it keeps
[Music]
going nice
audio very good trying to get the audio
for you guys at least yeah that's he's
basically pulling down at her intestinal
lining she hearing the sound with that
it was wild it's already wild so
uh my people said I acted out I did who
wants to come FL on the
table I'm
good Perry okay I think this is what I
have somebody texted Perry oral
dermatitis they said I'm pretty sure
this is what Ethan has I'm not a doctor
I dropped out of
college and I work for a Tru Trucking
Company per per perioral
dermatitis what does this
mean perioral dermatitis is a skin
disorder great it's a
disorder nice resembling acne or rosacea
wait hold on no I don't have it doesn't
look like acne or rosace in most cases
it involves tiny red bumps that form on
the lower half of the face that doesn't
sound like it right holds the nose and
around the mouth
yeah I still go with lupus probably
seems more likely yeah I thought we
confirmed that it was lupus with the
poll earlier usually self- treatable it
says resolves within
months
great
great uh so here I wanted to say people
keep bringing this
up chiropracty and we haven't talked
about this yet
somehow was invented
by ghosts
um that's true the first
chiropractor he was a dude named DD
Palmer it origin originated in the late
19th century D in Iowa Mega dooo Yo once
some dude in Iowa talked to a ghost and
now people in Russia are having mallets
driven into their back
[Music]
thanks pal Palmer theorized that
misaligned spinal vertebrae
what she uh termed
subx interfered with the body's innate
intelligence a vitalistic life force and
were the cause of various Health
ailments sounds scientific he proposed
the adjusting these it sounds like
Scientology a
bit mhm he proposed the adjusting you
know these are thetans the subluxations
are thetans and we have to purge them
they could restore Health by allowing
the body's innate intelligence to flow
freely the does that mean innate
intelligence yeah I thought it was
free 19th century was awesome wasn't it
in 1895 Palmer performed the first
chiropractor adjustment on a janitor
named Harvey
Lillard he claimed to have his hearing
restored
wow that was right out of the gate first
try mhm I hope incredible yeah so you
guys see the this is often cited as the
birth of
chiropracty so uh I don't know talk if
you have hearing loss talk to your
chiropractor I hope you can hear me back
there dude
chiropractors convincing like the vast
majority of the populace that this is a
legitimate scientific practice is nuts
these people are suos scientific
dangerous
lunatics not all of them I have actually
I've actually seen some being really
fair like modern chiropracty is totally
insane that's not what it's
about yeah I you know these examples on
Tik Tok that we're finding are like
pretty extreme I think most of it's
pretty and I think there's a lot of
overlap with like Physical Therapy hold
on yeah physical therapy is a real thing
and it makes sense because it's like
stretching and strengthening muscles
that makes a lot of sense but I'm
talking about your average
chiropractor you know and all your major
cities these guys are all quacks they
are not I'm just telling you it might
relieve it you know I'll give you a
little Placebo relief
but they ain't restoring your hearing
I'll tell you that DD Palmer had a
variety of beliefs that were outside
mainstream both in healthcare and other
domains innate intelligence that's what
he said at the core of his chiropractor
Chiropractic philosophy was the idea of
innate intelligence a spiritual life
force he believed was responsible for
the body's Health oh that's like an
anime yeah
this theorized this oh I like him now I
like
anime this Force he theorized could be
hindered by spinal misalignments or
subluxations
subluxations he also believed in
magnetic healing before founding
chiropracty Palmer was a practitioner
and promote promote proponent of
magnetic healing a type of alternative
medicine that posited illness resulted
from imbalance in the body's magnetic
Energies
[Music]
so he also had religious undertones to
his uh practice Palmer sometimes
discussed chiroprac with religious
fervor he saw himself as chosen Reed the
knowledge of chiroprac and made various
biblical references in relation to his
discoveries some of his writings even
compared himself to other religious
figures so wasn't wrong in the elron
hubber comparison he also believed in
reincarnation Palmer claimed that
principles of chiropracty were revealed
to him from the spirit of a dead Doctor
my
friends you know what's interesting I
also heard that's how Rheumatology was
they found out about that through a dead
a dead Doctor Spirit Rheumatology mhm
yeah are you sure that's I thought it
was oncology I thought it was actually
fighting cancer I think it from a ghost
it was Urology or oncology Urology yeah
dick the dick dick um let's see list of
uh areas of medicine invent Ed by
ghosts it's a good question let's
see presumably ghosts have more
knowledge than we do right they have
access to H weird more info most of
what's coming up is
about chiropractors I don't see any
other area of medicine it's a famous
ghost that one is special Casper
specifically hold on many invented by
Casper the Friendly Ghost uh so he was
it was given to him by the spirit of a
dead doctor he also claims to have had
memories of past lives including being a
physician in ancient civilization
according to Palmer the basic principles
of chiropracty was revealed to him by
the spirit of Dr Jim
ad Atkinson a deceased physici this
Revelation allegedly took place during a
seance a popular activity during the
19th century where individuals attempted
to commune with the dead he showed up
like a force ghost we did one of those I
believe him
uh opposition to vaccines Palmer was
notably skeptical of vaccines I only
take my medical advice from ghosts thank
you very much mhm including the use of
vaccines he believed that correcting
subluxations rather than vaccinations
was the key to preventing
disease so the context is certainly
interesting uh when considering the
efficacy of chiropra it is interesting
that it stuck around though right
because I mean there was a lot of like
wacky ass 19th century medicine you know
it's kind of the era where people were
starting to figure out medicine you know
I'll tell you it's because like
chiropracty has
this it lends itself to this
I an air of credibility because like in
a sense it make it makes sense almost on
face valy you're like yeah crack the
bones and you hear it you hear the crack
mhm so it's like there's you feel it you
hear it you see it and you're like sure
yeah my spine's misalign let's just you
know that's how it works
right and yeah often times it does feel
good like I I crack my Knuckles like
religiously like all the time MH right
so I understand why yeah but this dude
is straight up giving Mal vampire uh
Mallet to the back
Vibes here I am with a
spine he looks crazy I took this from
crazy
guy yeah he's the man DD was just the
style at the time but uh that's a man
who knows ghosts yeah someone someone
made a a statue to him he's got his
hands on the shoulder of the ghost the
the ghost is sitting there too he's
about to snap his neck actually here he
is curing cancer in one of his people
curing
hearing it does look like he's getting
ready to do a chiropractic adjustment
that is what he's doing yeah d so is DG
Mega dooo me
Doo and that's all I have to say about
chiropractor today okay in fact that's
all I have to say about anything
[Applause]
today
nice
uh so
buttons you ever heard that
you say so and then they say so
buttons button
button okay thanks everybody okay all
righty been a podcast it's been
one let see if there was any last
messages here yeah I don't really want
to talk about the before you have
acupuncture check out Dr Mike's
experience with the LOL he got messed up
what wait Dr Mike went through that pull
it I'll investigate
that if it's fast I'm curious oh we'll
have to stay the eel pit for later
guys
um oh yeah he has a video my terrible
experience as a patient The Worst Doctor
Ever wait is this about acupuncture wait
acupuncture I thought was about
chiropractor no no that's what before
you have acupuncture check out Dr Mike's
experience with send me is this the yeah
this is it oh yeah acupuncture accident
oh God I don't even want to imagine what
that means wait how it's like you just
put it in a spot How does it go wrong I
think you just I just think you hit a
nerve I think that's the bad part well
let me hear what he has to
say uh I mean it's a it's a 10-minute
video uh do you want to all right we
we'll do it next time we'll find out
we'll look into it I was supposed to do
it now I'm if Dr Mike says no I mean
he's my out of it no
you think it got a nerve isn't that the
whole
point that's what I thought unblocking
cheese Chandra will never do you like
that I didn't think so oh yeah it does
say in the time stamps nerve damage so
uh interesting I'm sure that's no biggie
I think he got a shoty acupuncture
nerves grow back right right I think
he's blaming um yeah I think it was his
fault what a little needle did a nerve
damage maybe he should have moved his
nerve
uh Ethan straw itch might Oak itch
might stero Derma doas did you what
the did you say to me stero Derma
domisum might use baby WIP speak in
German I thought so but no that's all
English use baby wipes and 70 to 9%
rubbing alcohol doctors don't know about
this doctors hate this one
trick also parasitic worms from dogs can
be found your eyes stop don't stop with
the that is yo you got
worm eyes bro doctors hate this one
trick no thank you for the advice I
appreciate it I'll take everything into
them worm eyes bro
nasty yeah um touching stop stop it oh
I I didn't realize but yeah I don't
I don't want to talk about this whole
conflict anymore really at all
ever and uh I'm frankly also thinking
about
putting
uh something that I need to discuss with
hisan
but I do feel like I'm probably going to
pause leftovers for the time
being you know what I
mean okay
Ethan cuz I you know what I mean it's
just I don't I don't want to talk about
it
anymore that's it and it sounds like a
lot of y'all don't want me to talk about
it
either
fair so with all that being
said I shall
go suffer at home in Silence with worms
infecting my eye
sockets
and I would just sit at home and stare
at the wall in silence and in
dark for that
is what I
deserve you can end
[Music]
it